These are pretty cool. And we're live. Hello Steve? Yeah, that's the Kanye one.
That's the most recent. That's a Skype plasta cell. Phong Tran. He uh,
creates all these, he hand paints each one. They're really not. Yeah,
he sculpted. It makes like a mold. And then he's got a bunch of dope ones.
It's all on his line. And you've got a book bro. I do call it noise blue.
The color of noise. Yeah. What's this about?
It's my memoir. It's um, uh,
talks about the beginnings, um,
goes through my process. It goes through a lot of different things. I mean,
at the end of the day I spend more, so it's more about,
it's less about what's happening now and more about like how I got there,
you know, the story and different piecemeals stories that,
that are thematic and you know, with this overarching idea of blue,
which is like the different shades of blue of my life, it's my favorite color.
And actually my last name is means blue tree. Really? Yeah.
Yeah. So it's like there's a lot of synergy with the color.
So when I was coming up with the idea to name the book,
you know, I had to think of like, uh, you know,
something that relates throughout my whole life.
So there's so many different shades, emotions,
feelings that are represented and all of these different stories.
Do you, have you always been a writer? Um, I'm like, uh, yeah,
I guess like a piecemeal writer, you know, I, I needed help finishing this book.
There's no doubt about it. I had so much. It's like, you know,
cause I still like, you know, have the pen and paper is still, you know,
like I grew up before, before computers and all that stuff. I was,
when I was writing, uh, lyrics for my bands, I was always like a notepad.
So I had just so many different stories.
I didn't know how to put it all together. Um,
I started the inception of writing, you know, the,
these different stories of my life six years ago.
And then I shot a documentary for Netflix and uh, we dropped it called,
it's called asleep and I'm dead. We dropped it three years ago, four years ago,
2015 to 16, I think. And I and I,
after I saw the reception on and how people responded to the doc,
then I knew that like, you know, this is really going to take shape.
Is it gonna be front centers finishing and,
and writing them a proper Memorial.
So the,
the idea of writing a memoir is only the idea of writing and writing about
yourself is only to write this memoir.
You sound like you write on a regular basis. No,
no, no. I mean, you know,
like I am actually coming up with some new ideas for the next, you know,
conception of what I would put out there in book form because it's a different
process for me that's quite exciting just to like the challenge to do something
like this. Cause I'm,
my natural way to express myself is through music and um,
and I love being able to step outside my comfort zones.
I think at the end of the day when you do that enough, you just,
you just get better as a human being and try, you know,
if you always do the same thing over and over again,
you're never really learning. So it's a,
it's been like a great learning process, you know,
putting out this memoir and uh, and, and,
and like actually opening up.
There's a vulnerable side to who I am that I, I don't necessarily,
I don't talk about really, you know, like for people that know me,
like my fans or my music fans or anyone else that know Stevie. Okay.
They don't really know what's in this book. You know,
they might have a glimpse of it from a documentary,
which I did because I talk really deeply about my relationship with my father
and,
and like this drive that I have as a kid to make it.
And uh, and it shows you enough where it's like, okay,
now I have a little bit more than my live shows and what's already out there.
But this goes, you know,
obviously a lot deeper because it's a book and we're going through emotions and
the vulnerability and, and um, and I,
I want to tell the stories of the hardships and at the end of the day,
I want to speak to young kids out there yet young people out there,
even the older people that are trying to figure their own thing out and,
and because the documentary related in so many ways,
on a personal level that I shared there,
this is how I wanted to share that through my own words.
Do you find that writing these things down and just thinking about your life
and,
and trying to express it in a way that's gonna resonate with people,
that this helps you think about it and helps you sort of a categorize it and put
it all in your head and cause do you know anyone? Do you know who that is? Yeah.
Yeah. Famous chef. Yeah, definitely. Yeah. He's a friend of mine,
great guy and writes every day. And I asked him why. I'm like, why,
why are you writing? Because he's written books, but he's,
he writes to sort of collect his own thoughts. Yes. Yeah. 100%. Yeah.
It's like once you, that's the trigger for me because even when I read,
I write right after, like what I gained from it. I'll almost like this,
like my note, my a homework. Yeah. For retention on,
on what I gather a takeaway from what I'm reading.
So I'm always like reading and writing or writing, scribbling in my,
in my book or, or like writing off the side and a note patter.
Like now I was like, you know, I look like a tablet or something.
But it's like you need to gather your, your,
your head space so you have retention.
Yeah. You right to understand, right? Yeah.
And then the right to express it so that other people can understand.
And in that process you kind of understand yourself better. Right.
[inaudible] sort of, Eddie described it and when he said it to me, I was like,
God damn. And I don't write enough like that. I write more comedy stuff.
I try and write material and essays on things and pull jokes out of them.
But like I think there's probably a great benefit for anybody to just sort of
write about your thoughts dear diary, you know, just that you know,
I mean there's something to that because in that time,
I mean you could speak to this because you've written a book on yourself,
but in that time of writing about yourself and reflecting upon your life,
you probably learn a little bit about who you are and why you're the way you
are.
Yeah. And you know, thinking about this,
I never really thought about it to this point or found the,
the parallel here,
but when I started seeing a therapist to go into my past and try to break down
what,
like why make the decisions I do or like why I spiral out here or do something
that I am not comfortable with or I want to change. A lot of that I'm able,
like after the sessions I go and start writing, you know,
and then a lot of that, you know, eventually makes it in the book.
Do you run long hand or do you write on a keyboard? I, I would do both now.
I do both, but like I have scribbles of stuff everywhere, you know?
But then I made like at the end of the day for organizational purposes,
it's just gotta go in. Like I gotta do put it in a computer, you know? But,
um, yeah, this is a very, this is my own therapy. You know,
as you could say, it's like,
it is putting all these stories and these memories and the feelings and the
emotions and the hardships or whatever it might be. You know,
it's like, I think the hardest part is like picking the right ones, you know,
the end of the day
when you put all this stuff together and you spend so much time on this,
do you find that the process of that in any way enhances your music?
Yes, it does. Because I mean, when I think about,
first of all, I think about the process of making music. I think about it,
a very simple, similar to what you're doing when you're,
when you write for your comedy skits and you're efficient, you're like,
okay this is going to work cause I want to be able to share it this way.
You know, just writing your thoughts down. Right?
So like when I'm in the studio, I'm very efficient. You know, I'm like,
I'm going and going, I'm going to make a club thing or just for the festivals.
So the crowds go crazy and it's less about the emotional message.
You know what with this, being able to talk about that side, that's,
that adds that other layer that that I'm,
I'm seeing now more than ever in the last like three or four years when I
started making songs with lyrics that actually, you know, I've, you know,
seen the fans come out and drove saying how much it's gotten them gotten them
through hard times because the lyrics were able to speak to them in a certain
way. So it's, and that's the essence of collaboration at the end of the day,
you know, working with songwriters and singers and,
and being able to be pulled in that direction is incredible. As an artist,
you know, instead of just having like, all right,
we're making this record to make everyone go crazy,
even though essentially electronic dance music is all about the music. Yeah.
It's not about, you know, the touching lyrics.
They might be like the flavoring on top, but the,
the foundation is all about the beat, you know.
But now it's like about mixing both worlds as much as possible, you know,
cause at the end of the day, when you think about my shows,
it's a very full on experience. Like when I, when I put on a show,
I'm trying to, like, I'm trying to come compound all the senses, you know,
I want it to be entertaining as hell. I want it to be fun, engaging.
Um, I want you to leave knowing that you saw Steve Aoki show.
So that's why I try to do different, unique things. Like, like, you know,
I cake people. I don't know if you know this cake.
People at my shows take them like you hit them in the head with cakes. Yeah,
I would say the head but yeah, but this is all consensual by the way. So
I'll give you those. So you know,
I think as you are on the stage all the time, you want to make your skits,
do you want to make your, everything that you do unique to Joe Rogan, you know,
like you don't want to be like, Oh yeah, he's a copy of this person.
No one wants to be that, you know? So I'm thinking like,
what am I going to do that's going to be unique and different? Engaging. Um,
Hey, Oh, you know, like everyone's doing that. Everyone sit down,
everyone jumped. So you know, I'm like, you know, your brain's always thinking.
So I got an idea after a song that I really saw my label.
I have my own label and we,
we released this artists where the video was cakes exploding in people's faces,
super slow motion, high-def. Really beautiful. And then I was like,
you know what? I'm going to go to a bakery,
I'm going to buy a cake scribble like the song on the top of the cake and let's
just see what happens. It'll be funny little thing, you know, and I,
I brought the kisses 2011 mind you, so this is seven years or however long ago.
That was it, you know, long time ago, I didn't do the math anyway,
so it was a long time ago and I walked around the front of the stage and one of
the, one of the kids in the front, one of the guys up front was like,
why is he walking around the front? Like, am I supposed to like grab it?
And then he just starts pointing at his face and then all his friends around him
are pointing at him and the whole place was just staring and waiting and
watching and wondering what the hell is gonna happen? So like kicked him,
we filmed it before, this is pre Instagram, put it up on YouTube. It's like,
I gotta do this every show. This is incredible. And then six months later,
people started coming out with cake. Me signs.
Six years later, look at the, okay, here we go. So six years later,
like I think I've kicked over 15,000 people now. You know.
Oh my God, Jesus like gonna go crazy. You hit it right in the mug too,
dude. Perfect shot. Well, I'll tell you, I mean, you know, it was just,
practice makes perfect, you know? Yeah. You've thrown 15,000 kicks. I get you.
Get you get a feel for it. Look at her. She's dancing. Yeah. Wipe it up.
Let me see one more time. This is like a, that was all tra.
Oh my goodness. We have a cake rider. We have very specific cakes that are,
you know, uh, at our show you have a S it's like a special Aoki cake.
What is in it? The strange thing is,
is there is like not as much cake as you would think. It's just like frosting.
It's just so it just explodes everywhere. So it's less bread. Yes.
Just so like less carbs, more sugar. Well, if you're diabetic,
just get out of the front row please.
What a crazy thing for people to enjoy. To get kicked in the face. Yeah.
When he was having a good fucking time. That's okay.
That's the most important thing at the end of the day is like my shows take me
with a bullseye. Okay. This is very normal for me to see.
You know, like some cases there's like 50 50 people with signs up.
So crazy. Look at that cake face. One of the, Oh, I'm watching my face.
Yeah. I mean it's just, it's a signature part of the show. It's fun.
It's exciting. Um, dude,
I need to go to one of your shows because everybody that I know that's been said
as it's wild experience, not just music, it's just there's something,
you're doing something transformative, you know that people come out of there,
they're just like woo, they're buzzing. Yeah, yeah, fine. That's the goal.
You know? And if I, if I feel like I'm doing that,
if I feel like I'm really having this impact,
then I go that not, that's why I end up doing like so many shows. Cause I,
on average, I'm doing about 250 shows around the world every year.
That is so crazy. And I do this,
I've done this consistently for over 12 years. So it's,
it's a,
it's not like an artist that just drops an album and then they tour like around
the world for a year or two. Like I'm on, I'm on a worldwide tour,
you know, every, every single year. Is that sustainable? How,
how's your body holding up? I need to work out a lot. Yeah.
You're really into health and wellness and all that stuff.
But that seems insane. Particularly with all the travel. It does. I mean,
you have to, you have to like treat yourself like an athlete, that's for sure.
Um, the way I think about my regiment is different, you know, and I,
and I'm like obsessed with, uh,
trying out new ideas,
using myself as a Guinea pig to work with different scientists,
sleep doctors, uh, you know,
different people in various fields that are testing new ideas to like deal with
jet lag or things that I am dealing with the, they're on the road that,
that can wear you down and make it not sustainable. Do you do IVs,
uh, like STEM cell? No. No. Like vitamin, like vitamins or anything like that?
Not as, no I don't, but I, you know, like I,
at one point I was,
I wasn't down the same road as Ray Kurzweil doing 250 vitamins a day,
but I was probably, you know, experimenting with about 50. Have you met him?
I have. He's an interesting dude. Yes. Yes. He's
quite a trip behind his eyes. There's a lot going on. Yeah,
absolutely. And, uh, I mean my,
so like I have a whole album series called neon future.
So I have neon future one, two,
and three that just came out my out my albums and each album, um,
I actually work with a scientist on a song. Oh wow.
So I had Ray Kurzweil on on one.
So he's talking on a song about like life expansion, life extension, um,
big singular, not necessarily Singletary nut,
but like I'm a big fan of the idea that we can live indefinitely.
I'm an enthusiast of that world. I might not, not definitely not an expert,
but I'm an enthusiast for sure. Yeah.
And I got JJ Abrams on to like an Aubrey de grey on two. Oh wow.
I've had moms, well, yeah. Yeah. And like I interviewed him, I went to,
I went to res Ray Kurzweil's apartment in the Bay area.
Yeah. Yeah. So I mean,
I know that we have lot of synergies on the science and tech stuff.
And three I'd bill Nye. Oh wow. And four, which is coming out next year.
I'm having my favorite author on the album that I've read so far.
So I'm very excited. Have, I, you know, I might as well now.
I might as well announce it here if I'm going to announce it anywhere.
I haven't announced it yet, but you've all heard already. Oh wow.
I love that guy. Yeah. Sapiens is amazing savings. My favorite book,
I'm on the second one right now. Yeah. I was just finished on with Davis and uh,
I mean he has a very like C I think of the future very positively.
It's a neon future. Yeah. He doesn't think of it totally so rosy. Yeah.
But you know, I like his, I like his, uh,
his analysis and you know,
the way he's trying to understand how we've evolved or pushed out outwards.
Yeah. And I agree with a lot of what he's saying. Well,
why and why what he's saying is irrefutable.
But what's interesting is the way he sort of coalesces it,
the way he combines it all and you really get a sense of, wow,
this is what a person is like, this is how it all went down. You know,
he's a brilliant guy too.
I've seen him interviewed really fascinating character. Yeah. You know?
Yeah. Opry degrades a trippy dude too because he drinks so much. I know I've,
I've hung out with him and like, like pint after pint, I'm like, Hey man,
aren't you supposed to be the fucking wellness longevity guy?
He's so in,
in trenched in science that he thinks that the solutions are going to come
through the laboratory. Right. He, he,
I mean he doesn't seem to exercise if he does, I think he just Rose a boat.
Have you seen that? Like he like Rose boats around the Harbor,
wherever he lives in England and um, he drinks,
I think it's in his beard though. The boos, the beard, the beard is his,
his like magical wizardry. And I've actually that's against science, but,
but uh, yeah, he's a very interesting guy. He jumped,
I have a foam pit in my house.
He jumped in my foam pit watching 50 year old man with a beard down to his
blows, nipples jump into foam pit. It's actually pretty
cool. That is cool. A scientist as well, you know, this like, you know,
it's cool that he's willing to be silly. Yeah, exactly. You know, like, and I,
I have a, uh, you know, have the Aoki foundation, which I'm wearing. It's,
I'm obsessed with the human brain. So all of our, um,
our money that we raise goes to brain research organizations,
brain science orgs and uh, but also like, uh,
or said deal with anti aging or anything that's interesting that relates to, um,
you know, living longer, healthier lives. And one of which is a sends org,
which is Aubrey's org. Have you ever heard,
you didn't know who David Sinclair's, uh, remind me,
uh, he's a Harvard professor. He's on the podcast next week. Uh,
he's been on before but he is at the front of the line of anti anti-aging
technology. And the podcast I did with him was incredible. He's a brilliant,
brilliant guy dealing with things like NMN and you know, and uh,
NAD and all these different, uh,
drip infusions and concoctions and molecules that, uh,
lengthen telomeres, enhance the, you know, the,
the body's ability to regenerate and age much slower.
Really, really interesting stuff.
Well, the, I mean, I love that stuff. Yeah.
So how did you get in this?
Because your thinking about your own mind or is this just something you've
always been fast
created by? I think, uh, it, it started, um,
when after my F my father passed away seeing the death of your father,
he died of a, um, cancer,
but it started with hepatitis C from, um,
a boat accident he had in like the late seventies.
The boat accident gave him Hep-C, I don't know, happened a blood transfusion.
Oh wow. And then he,
I mean he was surviving with Hep-C for, for decades, changed his,
his, um,
interferon and the things that were keeping him going before there's a vaccine
or cure. This is all before then. Um, I'm not sure if there is, but, um,
I'm almost positive there is. But, um, yeah, I think there is, I think, yeah,
very expensive involved process, but that, that like hurts,
you know what I mean?
It's like if someone dies close to you and then like something like that
happens. Yeah. So this is all happening, right.
And I see him die and I'm also like, you know,
I think I know about health. I'm vegetarian, you know, this, that and the other.
I'm like sort of healthy. But after I saw him die,
I read books on cancer. I started reading, like try to research like,
what could I've done to help my father?
And I still have people in my life that I absolutely love that I want to learn
and share. Like my mother, like, you know,
anyone else that's like close to me that's getting older. And um, then it just,
I just, I just went on this like bender, like, you know,
reading books on anti aging and then, you know,
I'm really big scifi nut. So, if anything,
I love living between the world of science fiction and science fact and finding
out in that gray area what is going to be science fact in our,
you know, in our though as long as I'm alive, you know,
and there's a lot of things happening because I do agree with that, that uh,
that curve, that we are not moving at a linear rate, you know, we are moving,
I don't know if it's exponential,
but it's definitely between linear and exponential with technology,
with what we're learning in science and medicine.
And as I'm learning more about this stuff, my music career is also raising,
uh, my platform as a personality is, is also getting raised.
So then now I get to go and make a phone call to Ray and he'll answer and I
could get to meet him. And then I want to have fun too. So I'm like,
let's make a song. Let's do a video, let's do an interview.
So I created this whole neon future session so I can meet, you know,
Stanley rest in peace. Like, I got to meet him, hang out with them,
did an interview with him, took some photos. Emily, a Stanley Marvel who?
Stanley Marvel. Stan Stanley, the Marvel comics. Dan Lee.
I'm just going across the board here. Who? Stanley Marvel. But you know,
I'm like,
I just went across the board of all the people outside of my music space that I
can talk to, science people, science fiction people,
JJ Abrams to like whoever it might be. Um, even authors of books I've read,
like Richard Dawkins, I flew to Oxford university and I sat with him. Oh,
that's great. And, and I talked to him and he was, he was like,
I don't know why I'm here with you, but someone told me I should be, you know,
I think I'm gonna get the same response he's supposed to be coming on next
month. Yeah. And talk to him. Yeah. It's like you talk to him after a stroke.
No, this was a,
I remember him riding his bike to, to interview,
which is kind of cool seeing Richard Dawkins ride his bike.
It felt like Albert Einstein was coming at me or something. You know,
cause he's kinda like that kinda like, like he has a lawyer with him.
Um, yeah he does. But that was a 2015,
16 I think. So that sounds like around when he had his stroke. Okay. May,
I mean I actually wouldn't find out when he had a stroke. He's um,
recovered very well though. Apparently he's still has some residual issues.
Oh wow. So this is definitely pretty strongly. 2016. Yeah.
So this is pretty strong. Pre-stroke [inaudible] the,
the crazy thing is I've did all these interviews with all these different
people. Didn't, didn't actually post them up online. Why?
We did two with wired magazine.
We did the one with Ray Kurzweil and one with Stan Lee.
And I had like the rest lined up, but we wanted to, you know,
like present them the right way and go, Oh well that's actually, you're,
you're great on the internet. Jamie's the best.
And what's cool is that in his office? No, we got, um,
Oxford university gave us this room, you know, and uh,
I took it over.
That's awesome. With them. Do you, when you talked to Kurzweil,
did you get into his idea of being able to download consciousness? Um,
no, we didn't get that far, but I would love,
I'd love for you to tell me more about,
now it's a weird one because we went to this, uh,
I think it's called a 2045 conference in New York city.
And the idea behind it is that they think that somewhere around 20,
45 there's going to be some sort of a technological singularity with the
exponential growth or perceived exponential growth, whatever it is,
the leaping the in new innovations creating these new possibilities that
somewhere around 25, 20, 45,
there's going to be so many changes in so many new innovations that they believe
they're going to be able to put your consciousness either into some sort of a
hard drive, some sort of quantum computer,
or perhaps even a physical embodiment of a Steve Aoki. Like you have a,
an artificial Steve Aoki like a sleeve. Yeah. And then your co,
your actual brain right inside this thing.
So as your body dies now you will exist in this whatever the fuck it's made out
of. Right. You know, and he thinks he's going to be able to do that.
And you know he's got a really bizarre motivation too.
His father died when he was young and he didn't really get to know him that well
and he has all these images and all these terms and he thinks that he is going
to be able to in some way shape or form recreate his father and have some sort
of a, a reasonable facsimile. Some sort of a,
a way to communicate with this.
His dad actually have is with all the memories that he has of his father,
all the,
the video and images and actually recreate his father to have a communication
with them. It's very weird stuff. Yeah. I mean I think a lot of these,
those, those storylines get drawn out and, and scifi. Yes.
Cause that's essentially where we want.
Like we want to go without any issues and problems and,
and backfire and know like black mirror episode, you know,
kind of blender because I mean it, we are,
we are definitely going in that direction.
We're going on somewhere weird for sure.
We are 100% going there and there's no stopping it. No way. Yeah.
Every he's can't. Yeah.
Reds buying new phones and new technology and we're pushing it as far as we can.
There was a guy, um, I think it's from the university, Connecticut.
He is the preeminent researcher on time travel and he is right out of a fucking
Spiderman comic book. His dad died when he was young,
same sort of situation and he wanted to figure out a way to go back in time and
save his dad.
So he's literally trying to come up with a workable theory for time travel.
This, that's the gentleman, what is his name? Dr Ron mallet. Yeah.
Dr Ron mallet. And it's right now, I mean,
he's got a working but it's,
it becomes a matter of having enough energy to actually pull this off.
But the idea behind it was all inspired by his father dying and he thinks he's
going to be able to, or someone may be able to go back in time.
But what he will hear stories like this, right? When you hear the story,
cause I know like this is like what you do. You get to talk to all these people.
Do you,
do you believe them to a certain extent and then you like you go because for me,
I need the scientific understanding, you know, like yes,
I'm not too much into the paranormal.
I need to like understand too to see if the sexually is conclusive.
I think he found out something unfortunate, uh,
in that the idea as far as time travel as we know,
it will only exist from the time the time machine is invented forward and
backward to that moment. The idea like Terence McKenna described it,
the idea that you cannot travel where there are no roads and so once a road is
established, then things get really fucked up.
Because if you create a time machine as Lisa's in terms of what they understand
or what dr Malick believes about time travel right now,
and I hope I'm not butchering, I'm sure I'm butchering it,
but I hope not pushing it too bad.
You can only travel back to the moment the first time machine is invented.
So once that door is open, then time ceases to become linear.
Anything from the end of time till the invention of the time machine happens all
at once because anyone can come back to that moment because it time machine
exists now, it's made. So of course they're gonna innovate.
Anyone in the future is going to innovate.
These people that do innovate are going to have a much,
much superior version of this time machine and everyone's going to be able to go
back to the moment that the time machine is invented in any point along the way,
from the end of time to the beginning of time,
from the moment that time machine is invented. So in that case,
if that really is the case, yeah. Has a time machine been invented?
I don't think it has Y well, I could be wrong,
but what's your like I think everything is going to be completely fucking Gonzo.
You're going to have people appearing and disappearing and showing up and going
and it's a normal thing. It's like, Oh yeah, he's traveling through time.
It's just that like all events,
say if like you would you know that w what if he was a world war five a hundred
years from now and you were like, fuck this,
I'm going back in time a hundred years before world war five and I'm just going
to live there. And they do.
They decided to do that or world war three or world war four there.
Just keep going back in time and forward in time.
You could go if you had a time machine and the time machine was, and again,
I'm butchering this, I'm a moron. I'm not a scientist.
If you had a time machine and time machines existed from now until you know the
perceivable end of the lifespan of the earth,
right when the sun supernovas and there's no more life left on earth,
you could kind of go anywhere you want from now to a million years now as long
as there's a place to go,
as long as there's a time machine available and the idea is that time as we know
it will cease to exist because our time now is dependent on, you know,
our biological entities waking up, moving forward. What time is it? Oh,
it's three on my meeting's at five better hurry, hurry over to downtown.
Traffic's rough this time of day.
All that stuff is going to be nonsense if there's time machines because you're
just going to be able to move anywhere you want at any point in time.
Sounds ridiculous, but so does the internet.
Have you brought the internet up to some guy who lived in Victorian times and
say, look at this. This is my phone and you can ask it a question.
I'll give you all the answers. Anything you want.
That would be the most astounding form of witchcraft ever invented.
And now my 11 year old daughter has one of those. Yeah. You know, I mean she,
she asked that thing questions all the time.
She gets answers to stuff all the time that we used to have to go to a library
forum. She could watch videos that just come out of the air. That's magic. Yeah.
And, but it's, we are accustomed to it. We adapt very quickly.
So the idea is that what this would do is change every aspect of reality as we
know it in terms of like linear time. It would no longer exist.
[inaudible] would only those people that know how to use a machine have access
to it. Well, I mean, wouldn't it be like cell phones?
Like eventually everybody gets one and we're talking about time, right?
So if everybody gets access to it a year from now or three years from now,
it doesn't matter because the time machines already been invented so they could
travel back to that moment and forward from that moment.
So the moment they turn that fucker on, everything goes haywire. Wow.
So let's, so let's not turn that thing on like, Oh well it's weird.
It's inevitable. People press get it. Yeah,
well they want to see if they can even make that happen.
I used to have a bit that I used to do about the big bang because they were tr,
everyone's always tried to figure out like what was the universal like before
the big bang. Like what, what happened? How was it created?
And when you look at the progress of technology,
my thought was that if you look at where we're going and we're constantly
innovating and people are constantly coming up with new and more impressive
forms of technology that one day we're going to create a big bang machine and
that this is what happens the every 5 billion years or so,
things get so intelligent, they develop a big bag machine and they sit around,
these dudes are on red bull and Xanax and simulation and one guy goes,
I'll fucking press it. And he hits the button and boom,
the whole universe starts all over again.
And if you had a big bang machine and you knew that if you pressed it within 5
billion years, humans would create another big bang machine.
This is an endless cycle. Would you press it? Fucking for sure.
There's someone that would press that button.
100% person out there that would press that button.
Yeah, no, I heard more about the simulation idea. Well that's another,
that's another idea. But that's, yeah, Ilan believes that he believes
that it's very possible. Like, like one of the things they said,
if you could ask AI, what would you ask? He said what's beyond the simulation?
Like he believes this is a simulation, but if you're Elon Musk,
of course you'd believe it's the simulation.
People letting you drill tunnels under LA and shoot rockets off into space.
You're making electric cars is solar roof panels.
I mean he's, he's literally living like some character in a movie.
He's like professor X or something. Yeah. But if you're in a simulation,
it's nothing you can do about it. Right? So you just might as well just do it,
do it all. So it's a great way to think about like what is a simulation?
If everything is a simulation, it's still life, right?
Like your existence is still everything you're accustomed to and everything you
experience. And if it is a simulation,
at least some aspects of this are comfortably or comfortingly,
uh, like obvious, like work hard, you can get better at things,
you can be nice to people, they're nice to you, like be be a good friend,
you get good friends, eat healthy food, you're healthier.
There's some comfort to the lack of,
I mean there's,
there's certainly some variables that are very difficult to account for,
but there's also,
there's a surprising amount of life that's pretty straight forward.
So if it is a simulation, it's not the most difficult one to follow.
It's pretty crazy and chaotic, but there's, there's a lot of comfort in it.
Like as much as we try to dwell on the horrors of humanity and I'm certainly a
lot of them because it guys,
a lot of beauty and people too and there's a lot of cool shit and people,
you know what I mean? When you focus on that, then yeah.
Then there's real growth.
I was at the comedy store last night until like two o'clock in the morning in
this comedians bar just hanging out with all these comedians.
We're just laughing and talking and this is no, no audience.
Just a bunch of people that get paid to make people laugh.
Like John steward was back there,
Michelle Wolf and all these really funny comics were all just laughing and
having a great time and talking and it was, I was like, wow,
this is so nice and it's so fun. It's rewarding.
It's like there's cool things in this life if you can find good people and
friends and,
and communicate and spread love and have interesting,
fascinating thought provoking conversations.
There's a lot of really positive things. Right? So this is a simulation.
It's pretty bad ass for Steve Aoki. Yeah, I definitely am for sure.
Joe Rogan people and shit. You know,
making a brain foundation. I mean, what a fucking great simulation you're in.
Absolutely. I think, yeah, it's like you, you can make what you want of it.
I mean, it's not,
it might not be the dream like the Eli Musk scenario right away,
but it takes time to get there. Well, you don't want that dream.
I don't want his dream. Yeah, exactly. His dreams crazy. I mean,
his dream of like, I mean, like you said,
he's just like almost a superhero is Bruce Wayne, you know, doing whatever.
You know, he's,
he's iron man, you know. Well, you know some, some cars have small engines,
right? There's Honda civics out there and then there's fucking rocket cars.
He's got some sort of crazy quantum rocket car engine for a brain.
If you talked to him. No, I haven't. He's a trip. He's actually on the,
on the list of people.
I would love to be in the studio with the make music with and you know,
just get into his mind a bit.
I've been putting that out there to the universe.
He's one of those guys and when you're talking to him,
you have this feeling that he's running code in the background. Why he's talking
[inaudible] he just gets bored with like regular mundane conversations and he's
got 50 million things going on constantly and he's also trying,
like he was talking about it to me about how difficult it is to manage his mind.
Like you wouldn't want to be me. I'm like, Oh
he thought he was crazy when he was younger cause he like so much was bouncing
around in his head and he realized that other people weren't like that.
And he's like, Oh no, no, but I'm alone. Yeah,
I mean like literally he's probably alone.
Who the fuck is like that guy in terms of like a,
a public intellectual who's responsible for so many groundbreaking technologies?
You know the number one electric car in the world, like space X,
tunneling under LA with the boring company and like fucking, he's a crazy man.
Fast. Thank God he's around though. Yeah, I didn't know people like that.
It's so cool to have like a true outlier. You know,
someone who's just really out there and Oh man,
he's constantly attacked and maligned and people are misrepresenting him and you
know, people like all the crabs in a bucket don't like it.
Then I try to pull them down to God damn smart.
All these people that fancy themselves smart, you meet that guy like, Oh,
okay, there's levels to this game. Yeah, no, he's,
he's like the top of my list just so you know, being his presence.
But I think it'd be very exciting to try to do a song with Elon Musk.
I'll ask him, well, after the podcast I send him a text message too. So he's,
he's probably busy. Yeah, I could, I could always make as easy as possible,
but just go to space X or Tesla or wherever that, Oh,
so what do you in particular, are you doing with this brain foundation? Um,
I mean,
I think one of the most important things is inspire people more about brain.
The brain, you know, like, uh,
I mean obviously it's to raise money for brain research works. Uh, for one,
finding curious for degenerative brain diseases and to just understanding the
brain more,
working with [inaudible] that want to understand the brain more so that we can
expand what our limitations are. You know,
in the conversations that we're talking about, you know,
bring some of the science fiction science fact, you know, um,
I love this idea that like, you know,
telekinesis is when you can move things with your mind as soon as possible.
It's, it already is really not like in the supernatural sense. Like Magneto.
Well, you know, it's like, you know, there's, I mean, it's happened like
five years ago. People moving wheelchairs with their, with like, uh, implanted,
they planted. Yeah, exactly. I'm not sure that the right terms,
but I've seen the videos, you know, like a monkey being able to move,
uh, an arm to its mouth to eat the Apple. Yeah, those were happy. Those,
it happened like 2013 or 14 or fact check that.
But it was not 2019. It was like years ago.
So whatever they're doing at DARPA, whatever they're doing at like Google,
whoever's got these research orgs and labs I wanted,
I would love to jump in there and just like put my ear out there and just listen
and find out what's going on. And, you know,
cause I have my own interests and passion on what, what the breakthroughs are.
And I would also love to try some of these things.
Do you think they'd let you then? Sometimes, I mean, listen,
you got to try this. Boston dynamics might be your best bet though.
The raw the robot people. Yeah. They might let you in,
but DARPA's DARPA, DARPA, DARPA won't let me in.
Obviously they will not let me in. You're gonna have to sign some paperwork,
but I want to get in to as many doors as I can on any of this kind of stuff.
And uh, that's like my own personal gain. But also with the,
with the brain or I get just the brain foundation. It's just, uh, like,
you know, help out the smaller orgs too that are, that are one,
find the cures. Because at the end of the day,
what I've learned is that if you don't die of cancer or heart disease,
you're going to have a brain degenerate disease. You're going to,
you're gonna go crazy. You're gonna, you're gonna lose your memory,
you're gonna deteriorate. Yeah. And you know, you know,
years down the line we're going to be able to literally turn our body into like
a used car and change all the parts. Yeah. But you know,
if you start losing your memory, then you start losing who you are.
Did you talk to Kurzweil about those? Uh, yes.
It was years ago, so I'm trying to remember even like the interview that we did,
but I, you know,
I went in deep on a lot of the anti aging stuff and you know,
I,
I think the struggle that he's going to have is if he's going to make it to 20,
45 cause he's 70 or something. Right, right. Yeah.
And he has a heart. Um, he has a genetic defect with his heart, you know, so,
um, but it,
I mean he's just like one of those like those heroes of mine that I was lucky
too to be in his space, you know,
playing on his Kirksville keyboard and he invented the synthesizer.
Uh, that was,
that was a moment where both on the keys each to texts to didn't he? Yeah.
I think, I mean he's,
he's invented more than a hundred really significant inventions.
Yeah. Fascinating guy. Absolutely.
But can we squeeze 25 more years out of them? Yeah, yeah.
His biological life to get to 20, 45 because if he's going to like,
he's going to be one that's going to really
push that envelope part. I think he's, if there's anyone out there and so I'm,
I, you know, it's clearly obvious why Google picked him up. Yeah. You know,
and had him like head the whole, I forgot what the department is called,
but you know, well, didn't Google by Boston dynamics as well,
the Bata robot company. I know that, which is like, what are you guys planning?
You can control everybody's email.
You have the number one search engine on the planet earth, you have a,
the number one browser. Like what are you guys doing?
What are you doing over there? Yeah, you make them robots,
but don't you want to be in the room? Yeah, you don't want to be in the room,
but you know, some of their choices are a little bit questionable.
There's so much, there's, there's science, but then there's so much,
there's social decisions, you know,
that they're making in terms of like what people get to see and talk about in
here. And a lot of is based on the zeitgeists is based on the, you know,
the current state of politically correct ideology and what you can and can't say
or can and can't do.
And that becomes really dangerous because you're kind of controlling
information. You're throttling information. Like, you know,
Tulsi Gabbert is suing Google for, what is it,
like $50 million or something crazy like that.
They say that they purposely stifled her search engine results so that people
wouldn't be able to find her as easily and they've, she's apparently proven it.
Wow. Excuse me. Um,
so it's not a pure information based company.
There's ideology behind it, there's motivations behind it that you know,
politically leaning motivations right now.
So I don't know what goes into that though,
when he goes into that world on like, Oh, I,
you forget about that sometimes when you're like, I want to be in the Bay.
Right. Their rooms, you know. Well there was a,
an internal memo that were they referring to Ben Shapiro and someone else?
I think it was Jordan Peterson and maybe Dennis Prager as Nazis,
which is hilarious cause both Ben Shapiro and Dennis Prager are both Jewish.
So it's like their, their perception of who a person is. This was brought up,
this is brought up by, um, um, people in, in Congress.
Like they had to have hearings on it. I was trying to figure out like,
what is Google doing? Like, what are you allowed to,
how are you allowed to define people internally in your memory memos?
And then of course once you call someone a Nazi,
then you can act as if they're not seen and you know,
stifle any sort of search on them or stifle results or you know,
point point people in the direction that you think would be better for humanity
versus just pure information. And it gets, it gets very weird, you know?
But as a technology company,
look at their amazingly just what they're doing with Android and Google
searching and Google assistant and Google maps is by far the most,
the superior map application on the planet earth.
And it's constantly getting better, constantly gathering up new information.
I mean, part of me loves the fact that they exist and part of me is like,
Dan is too much power, has too much power for one,
one company to be able to influence people one way or the other. So what's, uh,
what's your, so what's the Joe Rogan solution to something like that?
Regulations. No mom too stupid for this. This,
I need to rely on people that have actually spent real time studying the effects
and understand it from a, a very deep level. I don't,
I understand it that it's, I understand that it's problematic.
I just don't understand what the solution is. And I don't know if it's even,
it's just a free distribution of information across the board because then what
do you do about actual Nazis?
Like if you find there's a new Hitler and he arises and he really does want
exterminate the Jews, what happens there?
Do you just allow that guy to be on Google?
Is he on Google Hangouts with little Nazi hanging out?
They're planning on exterminations and where are they? Where's the next, um,
Auschwitz, you know, no, I don't think that that shouldn't be the case.
So what is the case?
Do you allow white supremacists on there to organize rallies, FOC,
um, where, where does freedom of speech and you know, yeah,
it's very complicated questions. Yes. We're all learning to navigate.
Yeah. I think in many ways,
and this is a weird thought that I have and I repeat it over and over again,
but I think technology is going to provide us with a new way of communicating
that's not dependent upon language, but rather can read actual intent.
Like an actual mind reading technology. And I, when I,
when I see Elan's um, a neuro link,
this thing that he's trying to deal with,
they're opening up the bandwidth to humans and information through use of
implants and some sort of a Bluetooth wearable device like that I think is like
a step in that direction. And I think Ellen and you know,
in many interviews he said that he thinks that human beings are the organic
biological bootloader for [inaudible] for artificial intelligence.
So if we're a bootloader for AI,
the way to sort of combat that as boot loader boot loader. Yeah. Like,
like a computer boot loading already system. Gotcha.
That what we're doing is we're the biological blah, well,
the way I've described it is that we're sort of an electronic cocoon that's
about to make the butterfly and that we're,
we're at the Caterpillar that's making the cocoon and we're constantly in
pursuit of innovation or fly is the AI. Yes. The butterfly.
Like if you see a Caterpillar,
that kettlebell doesn't know what the fuck's going on.
It's just making a cocoon. That's what it does. Yeah.
And that's what it knows to do. Yeah.
And the idea is that we don't know what the fuck we're doing either.
Like why do we need five GS, four G not good enough. God damn,
I get on the internet pretty God damn quick. What are we doing?
What seems like five GS better and will be better than five G? Yeah.
And if you want to get that mind reading software,
you've got to get seven G and we're,
we're gonna do this to the point where one day there's going to be a real thing
sitting.
Well we will merge with the AI because that's,
I mean that's the future that I hope for you don't lose yourself in that,
you know, like,
but are you yourself,
once you've merged with the AI and then what's holding you back? God,
all these emotions are bullshit. That's getting into right.
Let's get rid of those. Let's just have pure people. Yeah.
Pure people now available through Nabisco.
It's interesting cause I, cause like my whole point with neon futures,
the convergence of [inaudible] the ultimate goal is you have cricket versus to
have technology and our humanity to the point where we live, you know,
forever through, you know,
this downloading system that we're talking about earlier on or, or you know,
whatever seemingly makes sense in the trajectory of where technology is going.
You know, so we do live indefinitely, you know, I mean that's like a
for me as well, you know,
my insurance policy for if I don't make it to this point,
like my dad didn't make it to that, that cure is, you know,
obviously a CRO genically freezing the body while I'm already signed up.
Jeez. So, you know, cause I feel like, I mean if we are really,
this discussion is, are we gonna make it there in our timeline?
I'm 41 so I've a better chance of Ray Kurzweil, obviously. Yeah.
So if I know, and I really believe that, you know,
I guess it's hopeful, you know,
that that will get to this point in our generation that will,
they'll make it what? It's that close, right?
So either we make it and then I die and then everyone lives forever.
Do I want to be the generation that of people that die or the generation of
people that go, Oh, death is as a cure. We just, uh, we just found,
we found a cure for death. Just like a cure for cancer.
Just like a cure for whatever.
What if after your biological body ceases to function,
you move into a new realm of reality that is a completely different dimension
that's filled with love and understanding. Like the after death. Yeah,
there's no room. We don't know. There's no biological shortcomings.
There's no emotions and there's no fear, none of that. And there's,
there's no bodies. You just, you're a soul in another dimension.
And then someone unfreezes you like, well, Steve wanted to be on frozen and
stuck back in. Kate. People are like, fuck man, I was,
I was there. I was on the other side. They're like, you'd be like,
click off doubt. No, I can't believe this.
And so then you go, well, I'll just die again.
Well here, here's, okay, this is, this is what I know. Cause I don't know.
I mean we both don't know what's really going to happen. That's likely. I mean,
anything is likely. Okay. I'm not saying that I'm not like a,
I don't believe in God or I do believe in God.
I'm just don't know what's really happening afterwards. But I know,
I know what I've seen as me,
what I understand of what's around me and my feelings is that if I wake up
tomorrow or if someone I love wakes up tomorrow with an incurable disease that's
going to kill them, it would be the most horrific thing.
And then I think at the end of the day,
the human race is going out to find cures for those kinds of situations. Sure.
So that's like, yeah, suffering, pain. I mean, that's what we do.
We try to stop any longer [inaudible] our life essentially.
We all want to live indefinitely, you know,
like through finding cures for all these issues. So we want to live healthily.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
You don't want to be in a wheelchair like for four 50 years,
just like staring at a TV and Hawkins. Yeah, yeah.
Which is w but, but then again,
like maybe he found all the silver lining, I'm not sure. But you know,
if you're healthy and moving and then boom, night and day are there,
of course it's awful. But, um, at the end of the day you just don't want that,
you know, like, I mean, I mean you, you don't want that kind of thing to happen.
So for me it's like I would rather opt out than have someone make the sunlight
disease, make that decision for me. The suffering things. Yeah.
The thing that we all want to avoid,
we want to avoid discomfort and pain and also causing discomfort to our loved
ones. Like one of the scariest thing about dying is leaving behind grievers,
leaving behind people that are sad and miss you terribly. Yeah.
It's like when you've seen people where their loved ones have died, it's, it's,
you know, I've lost loved ones.
We all have and it's a weird void.
It's a, yeah, it's horrific. It's traumatic. And it's, you know,
that's where my conquest or my interest in passion led to anti-aging,
the future, you know,
and then building on that for the ones that I love that are alive now, you know,
and doing whatever I can to like share the information so that they live as long
as they possibly can in the healthiest way possible. You know, so like,
I'm like just gathering, gathering information as I go, you know,
and it's, and it's exciting because as I was saying, it was, as I get bigger,
as a personality, you know,
sometimes I do jump into these rooms. And in one case, just recently, I,
uh, there's a doctor that, that just, that I've worked with,
I've gotten stuff done, some STEM cell injections with them in Denver,
and he came to my house and he was with some other doctors and they're like, Oh,
yeah, this is a doctor convention. I live in Las Vegas.
Those conventions all the time there. So they all came over and like, Hey,
you know, there's some breakthrough, um,
groundbreaking stuff just happened this year. Uh,
you can now find out on a cellular level, uh, uh,
cancer detection, uh, for at least 16 different cancers, you know, so like,
it's like very, very preventative, you know, far along the line.
So I was like, I want in,
so I got the information and I just liked that was a Christmas present for
everyone. What kind of STEM, so procedures are you getting? I
mean the first time was through, through Dan Bilzerian. He,
he's introduced me to uh, uh, the one in Panama, so I went down there.
Did Neil Riordan exactly. But my mom was just telling them, Oh yeah, last week.
Yeah, I've sent it down there twice. That's great.
And it was in the verge of getting a knee replacement and her knee was really
bad. And uh, eight months it was took a while, you know,
cause my mom was 73 and um,
within eight months her knee stopped being in pain and she was able to walk and
she can say they went to the grand Canyon and hazy. Yeah.
And now she went back again to just get a a second dose and juice it up some
more. It's incredible. I just know when I was there,
I saw a lot of kids in there. The one in Panama because it's it,
it grows muscle or does something like a, I don't want to say the wrong thing,
regenerates tissue. Right. So kids with muscle dystrophy,
kids with the like where they can't walk anymore,
they get the STEM cell injections and they can walk for 'em.
Then after six months, you know the,
the STEM cells to leave your body or are like the reason stay with you,
right? Yeah. So once again, I don't have scientific terms, I could be off,
but they have to go back in, get the STEM cells on. They can have, you know,
as, as you know, that kind of life instead of having me in a wheelchair.
So I went, I went in there, um, because I just wanted to try it out.
My friend also came with me. He has asthma, knocked out his asthma.
He never had to use an inhaler for way past six months. Really? Yeah.
Because the STEM cells also really affect the lungs. Um,
the umbilical cord cells, they,
they travel the lungs first from what [inaudible] Ivy virginity. Yeah. And Ivy,
we did Ivy.
I did shoulder my shoulders because I have,
I later got a, um, uh, rotator cuff surgery. Um,
cause I had like a bone spur going into my tendon,
but I try to use the STEM cells to sudden have to go to the surgery.
But you can't erode bone. Right. So yeah.
So you gotta shave down and so what they did exactly. Yeah. And um,
but I just liked my performance level went out.
The like the general kind of markers of what it's supposed to do actually
increase. Actually right after, um, right after that,
like I went back and I went back to Vegas,
met up with Dan and we did a workout and it was like, it's just, you know,
two times more and it, you know, it worked. Like, you know,
it did what it was scientifically supposed to do for me,
for my stamina, my energy. And, um,
you would did it for three days, do the three days,
three days and three days of Ivy and then injects into different joints and
exactly. And uh, that did that. And then about a year later, um,
I was with a dr Grossman, he's the doctor I work with in um,
he wrote the book with Ray Criswell called, uh, um,
I think it's the sub,
the subtext of the book is staying alive until we get tiller till who you reach
singularity or something like that. Uh, it's uh, it's like a,
a book on being healthy basically anti aging book. He wrote that in,
um, with uh, with, with uh, Ray Kurzwell. So that's why I heard about him.
I went to him a few years back to get like the full blood work going for me and
my family and want,
we did like two days of testing all kinds of stuff to learn more about our
bodies and see what we're deficient in, what we're not,
what vitamins we need to take to supplement the things that we're deficient in.
And I came back just, you know, maybe a year ago to do, um,
his version of STEM cells because in America is a different kind of thing like
Panama obviously out of America.
So they're doing the umbilical cord STEM cells where they harvest the STEM cells
from umbilical cords. So they have stage zero STEM cells. He's doing STEM cells.
It's almost like a plasma therapy when they took my blood spin it and they're,
uh, you know, pulling out the STEM cells from my own blood.
So it's 41 year old STEM cells.
But his point that he is saying is that the size of the STEM cells,
they're much smaller. So they're able to travel past where it ends up clogging,
which is like the lungs and like certain areas of the body.
So it does travel more. It just, it's not the days zero STEM cells,
but it's still effectively doing its work.
When you think back to like 20 years ago, there was no discussion of this.
So this is a completely, you know, I've had STEM cell shots too,
and I had a full length rotator cuff tear in my right arm that's gone.
Just it went sealed up. Well healed. Yeah.
I was having real problems with his arm where I was thinking I was going to need
surgery. Now it works great. No problems at all. Hit the bag,
lift weights and you, you injected intravenously and into the arm. Yeah,
I've done both. Yeah. Exosomes have done,
there's a new thing called Wharton's jelly that I had a pretty profound effect.
So very potent mixture of STEM cells.
We're getting close to the point where you don't have to go to Panama,
but go on to Panama right now is the way to go. So that's why you went for, no,
I didn't go to Panama and did it all in America.
Where Santa Monica place called the white spot. Denison. Yeah.
I have to try that out.
Some places that I originally started going to for Virginia King.
Do you know Regina King is Regena King, was uh,
originally invented in Germany and a lot of guys like Peyton Manning and Koby
Bryant, they had to flew up, fly to Germany back in the day to get this.
And what they do is it's a more advanced form of platelet rich plasma, right?
Like they're taking your blood out,
they spin it in a centrifuge and heat it through some process and they add
things to it.
And in the process it creates this incredibly potent antiinflammatory agent
that's from your own blood. It's like this yellow serum.
Then the inject this yellow serum directly into areas where you have injury and
or inflammation has a radical
healing effect and it's really, really good for bulging discs.
People that have disc issues of back issues.
And I had a pretty bad one in my neck that was keeping me out jujitsu.
My hands were going numb, you know, cause the,
the bulge was pushing against my nerve. Now it's gone. Like I've got a,
I've got an MRI six months later after the procedure, there's no more bulge.
Now, most of the time when you have a bulging disc,
sometimes it can go back and heal. But most of the time it does not.
And most of the time what happens is you wind up having to get a disectomy where
they go into the disc,
they removed the offending piece that sticking into your nerve,
but now you have a smaller disc, you have less disc tissue,
so your disc start to collapse your, your actual spinal column, you know,
the actual hard bone moves closer to the other hard bone and you know,
becomes a real problem. Arthritis forms, scar tissue forms.
The more disc tissue you have, you know the, the better off you are.
And they're able to do that now to the point where they increased the disc
tissue. Well it would, it doesn't decrease it. So when the disc is bulging,
it actually gets it to go back in.
It gets it to retreat and the STEM cells as the blood plasma therapy,
Regina King, but STEM cells have been shown to start to do that too.
They have actually started injecting STEM cells directly into Dick's disc
tissue. And I was talking to dr Roddy McGee out of Las Vegas. He's,
he's one of the guys that's really at the cutting edge of all this stuff.
Welcome with UFC fighters and they're doing that with them.
And he was the guy I originally went to to gr to treat my shoulder because of
Dr. Davidson from the UFC who's the main doctor for the UFC.
He was telling me he had shoulder surgery.
He's a little bit older than me and uh,
his shoulder surgery took [inaudible] but he was still having issues with it and
he was trying to figure out, um, what he,
what he should do cause he was still having pain when he was swimming.
Went and got some STEM cell injections. All the pain went away.
So he was telling me about that. He's like, you know,
you've got some pretty significant tears.
He might really need surgery but maybe this will help you for now.
So I went there and the, the, the amount of help that, the,
the amount of alleviation of pain and discomfort was stunning. How's,
I can't believe this is a real thing that you could just shoot this into
whatever is bothering you and then all of a sudden like four months later you're
like, where's the pain? I don't have any fucking pain anymore. I need to meet.
Can I, can you introduce me to Magee? Oh yeah, that's great. Yeah, yeah.
I'll give you his number. That'd be great. I send people to him all the time,
but he's on the cutting edge of everything. Like anytime.
He's a young guy and he's a really enthusiastic and super brilliant and anytime
there's any sort of cutting edge medical practice that guys, he's on it.
Like for instance,
one of the things they're doing now is when people get ACL tears,
which usually when you get an ACL tear,
usually you need reconstruction and usually with that reconstruction is either a
cadaver graft where they take the Achilles tendon out of a dead person and shove
it in your knee and then your body re proliferates that with its own cells.
It takes about six months and then you have a functional tendon again.
It's great. I had it done myself worse,
but now they're able to reattach the actual torn ACL with,
they have some special technique they do and they've had people tear and ACL and
then compete in the Olympics four months later. Wow. Which is fucking bananas.
That's crazy. Yeah. And he showed me this procedure and how they do,
and then he showed me this guy four months postop doing all these box jumps and
shit. And I was like, this is nuts. It is nuts. Wow. Yeah.
So there's a lot of hope and when in terms of regenerative medicine.
Absolutely. Yeah. And thank God for people like dr Riordan and Dr. McGee and um,
dr Ben Rui, who's the guy that I go to in Santa Monica.
I mean these guys are just on top of this incredible new wave of regenerative
medicine.
Yeah. I'm, I'm obsessed with that world. So the more you're talking about it,
it's like, uh, it's very exciting cause yeah, you're in Vegas.
You gotta visit Roddy. I would love to meet [inaudible] too. Yeah.
You'd love him. Yeah. And he's like super enthusiastic about it.
If he finds out that you're enthusiastic about it, he's,
he'll geek out with you. So that was awesome. Yeah. What else have you had done?
Um, STEM cells, um, shoulders, shoulder. I, I had, um,
I just had focal surgery, vocal cord surgery. Whoa. Uh,
did you get polyps or something? Yeah, I did. Yeah.
Paul deployed on my vocal cord cause I used to sing in a band. I used to,
I used to be a S like in a screamo hardcore band or a few of them.
I mean that's where like, that's my roots of who my,
where my music was as far as what led me to deejaying was being in,
in these like hardcore punk bands. So that's a lot of screaming.
Lots of screaming. Yeah. And then I carried that through when I finally,
like when I finally, you know,
retired that hat and I started deejaying years and years later and I started
doing these bigger, bigger shows and started doing the festivals.
I brought out that same energy again. And I started, you know,
when I started producing the music, uh, electronic music, all this,
bringing in guitars, I was screaming on some of these songs.
So I'm bringing some of my past in with my music and I'm back again,
but in a different world. Um, and, and I just, I,
I'm not, I, I'm not a trained singer, you know,
so I destroyed my vocal chords and I was just like raspy as hell.
Like I was just like an old Italian man, so my shows
and uh, and then I saw a doctor and he's like, you don't have a choice.
You're going to have to, like, you don't have to take a break. And I'm,
you know, I'm doing like 250 shows a year. So I was like, huh.
Cause stuff for the month and, and uh, and, and not talk for a month.
That was crazy talking for a whole month. Yeah.
Imagine Joe Rogan not talking for a whole month. Wow. A bit.
A lot of people would be excited, but I had to do that.
That was very hard. I actually saw a life coach before cause I'm like,
I'm terrified. I don't want my like demons or whatever,
anxiety or whatever things that I have like creeping up or they're like, okay,
your mind now you can't, you can't talk to someone about, you know, yeah.
Like I don't love scared, you know. But, uh, I, I got through it. I just,
I'm a very busy body kind of person. So like I just scheduled,
it was like going back to this college but with things that I needed to train
and get better at, like, get better at piano, get better at meditation,
get better at, at, uh, you know, twisting the knobs, engineering,
whatever it might be that I wanted to be better at it.
I just brought more people in my world.
Then I finished like an album in that month, making music with different people.
So I just was just so focused on creation and,
and learning and reading and you know, all that good stuff.
So when I left I was like, okay,
now I know how to do TM meditation or transcendental meditation and uh,
you know, I'm more comfortable doing the things that,
that help me be a better artist. Obviously worked. Right.
But what was the first sound that you made after a month?
What was the first word? I'll,
I'll tell you something that's really interesting.
I know now to do the most hygienic sneeze that you can possibly do.
Tell us because now I can sneeze with no, um, visible, uh,
vapor red residue. Cause you don't want any people sneeze. You can,
they see those videos. It's like, yeah,
it's like this cloud of trillions of bacteria floating in the air. Of course,
if you do that to me, you'll probably see some vapor,
but you don't feel on your hand if you sneeze and you just like you're,
it's all like gunky. And you know, it happens sometimes, right? Yeah.
Well now I can sneeze because I'm not using my vocal chords.
So as I sneeze I blow out really hard cause I had no choice.
I couldn't cough. I couldn't actually use a vocal cord after the surgery.
So what if you had to cough? So I'll be like, Whoa.
So like when I sneeze, I sneeze like that. I go. So if you do that,
if you do that kind of sneeze was that, that's how you do it, right?
That's how I sneeze. I just want to get some dust, see, see if you could,
if you could make me seize, I will show you. And then
basically, so you just breathe out. Yeah. It's,
it's the cleanest sneeze you could possibly do. Yeah.
So that's one very important thing I learned through this whole,
but the first sound, I mean,
I don't remember scared to say a word like when the 30 days was up. Yeah.
Yeah. It's probably just, you know, you know,
also whispering is really bad whisperings band like that. Yeah. Like,
yeah. So your healing whisperings not good for your vocal chords. Uh,
you think it's like
gentler on them. But from what I was told to not whisper.
So I literally was texting all the time for [inaudible], you know,
until I had to make that, you know,
you probably developed some fucking lightning fast thumb
wanting to get things out, but did,
that's what you did most of the time just text people, text to tie our,
it's called text to talk when I was in my meetings cause you know,
I've run various different, uh, you know, businesses and I have to, you know,
be on call. So I'm like texting a talk and I was Stephen Hawking. Yeah.
You know? Yeah, yeah. But yeah, it's like go back to yeah. Uh,
the agenda for two days. Yes.
They apparently wanted to give him a better voice and he didn't want it.
He was like [inaudible] they're more Siri like voice. Yeah. Sorry,
I didn't understand that. You know,
you can get Siri in nice English voice in his videos. He was not interested.
He likes that he liked while he was alive at that weird,
rough computer voice. He, I mean, from what I heard about him, he just,
his sense of humor was, was very funny and he's just a very sarcastic guy.
Seem you seem like a really interesting guy who also really likes strip clubs.
No, I did not. Yeah. Eric Weinstein told me about that. Remember? See,
there was a really interesting article written about him that, uh,
he would love to get wheeled into a strip club he liked, he enjoyed it and like,
like being there, but I guess that completely makes sense.
If you lost control of your body or still were attracted to women,
you can still found them amazing. You'd,
you'd want to see them naked dancing in front of you. Right. It's like,
it makes total sense. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Cause you want like, I mean,
exactly. You can't get it, but you can at least be there. Yeah.
What do you got Jamie?
There it is a claimed physicist talking a regular in California strip joint.
He's irregular. Wow. That's hilarious. That's pretty awesome.
Make it rain.
I am proud to say that I saw him speak when I was in college. Oh wow.
No kidding. Yeah, look at him. When all this trippers hollow.
Peter's Stephen Hawkings goes to her clubs. Look at him. That's amazing.
What does it look at? A smile. He looks so happy. He looks so happy.
Who are we to hate of the Lilly? Yeah. Um,
I would, I would imagine that would be a very trying 30 days.
So when it came, when it was over, was your voice normal? Did it,
did it come back? Did it, it was different,
but I was warned that it would sound a little different.
Like you sound different now than you sounded before the operation.
I'm used to what I sound like now,
so I almost forgot what I sounded like before,
but I think maybe a semitone differently, you know?
Um, but you know, it's like you just get used to new you.
Like if I was going to be half cyborg, half half man, I'd probably just be like,
okay, yeah, this is me. You know, like you just get to that when you've,
when you've situated in that the half sidebar,
things can be really weird when people start replacing legs.
Because I think if you could develop a leg,
like a cybernetic leg that's better than a normal leg, someone's gonna say,
chop my leg off and give me one of those, someone,
someone somewhere is going to do that.
And if that becomes seamless and you know, you get some Steve Austin,
$6 million man type shit going on, things he'd get real weird. That's uh,
what, um, you've all talks about and holidays, you know,
that whole idea that like,
first we use the technology to heal the people that need it,
but at the end of the day it's going to be used for advancing humanity.
You know, like there's like, you know, the, the, you want to save,
you want to help people that, that need to walk first, right? Yeah.
But then it's like, just like you said,
if it becomes very normal than the upgrades will be used as well to advance the
people that don't need it. Yeah.
And then we get to the point where you're unscrewing your head,
taking your brain out. And it's,
that's also what's interesting is that when you say that, you know,
now it sounds crazy. It does, but it doesn't, yeah.
Well to you it doesn't, but to me it doesn't either.
But that's exactly what you're saying about the phone too. You know,
or like what you're showing someone in the Victorian age. Yeah.
It's about the internet. Right. And when we get to that place,
it's gonna, you know, it's gonna feel like,
Oh well everyone, everyone did itself.
Like when Luke Skywalker got his arm chopped off and star Wars and they put
another arm on really quick, remember? Yup. Yeah.
That shit's going to happen. I believe it. Yeah. I don't think that's, I don't,
I don't think that's too far away. I think that's probably 25 years away.
I hope so. I think, I hope so too. Cause we're,
we are seeing some pretty advanced, um,
artificial limbs. So, um,
there was a guy that got his leg and his arm bit off by a shark and I met him at
the comedy store and he has this carbon fiber arm and a carbon fiber leg.
The guy doesn't walk with a limp.
He walks completely normal and he shook my hand. I was scared cause I was like,
don't crush my hand cause he's got some fucking iron man hand and he's,
he should have like the uh, does it look like a hand or is it just a metal hand?
Well yeah,
like a black carbon fiber hand that articulates it moves cause they're starting
to make it where you can feel. Yeah. So I think they are. Yeah.
So that way it's right there. Wow.
Yeah we've actually done that to the next level. Right.
It's like when you can make an arm that has nerve joints into this artificially
until it artificially connecting with your, with your brain. Yeah.
He's, he's an interesting character because that arm,
I mean it's, you w you really get this.
I am robot kind of feel from seeing his arm and his leg.
Like, cause it's,
I mean I'm sure he would tell you that he's much better off with his arm and his
leg back. But when you see the guy walk around, man,
he fucking just walks around. He looks normal. I mean,
what they used to have in comparison to what they have today.
I mean it is leaps and bounds and I'm sure the future.
So that's his actual arm. Wow. That's what it looks like. Wow.
Shark bit his fucking arm off. That's a, I mean, I,
I wouldn't want to put the arm and Lake yeah,
that was a hungry shark asshole. Yeah. It's a, you know,
it's interesting cause this is that we're in,
we're in this new frontier of what's possible.
I'm sure they're upgrading his stuff all the time as well, you know, and what's,
or what's available to someone like him. Yeah.
But it's exciting to see, like when you, when you like, you know,
when you see it firsthand and you see them not living and you know where we're
going and I'll like, Oh,
like I'm saying like all the scifi films that we see that some of them are going
to have very real, you know, scenarios in our life for sure. Yeah.
Yeah. Um,
are you a technology geek outside of the sort of, uh,
thinking about the body as in, I mean, I am of course, I,
I'd definitely say I'm a tech geek. Yeah. Because you kind of have to, right?
If you're, you create electronic music. Yes.
I'm a gadget guy too. You know,
I love like gadgets and trying new little things that are out there. Um,
you know, like I just want to try it all.
I want to like experience things in different ways to enhance my experience
overall. Yeah. Creating music electronically is,
it's kind of polarizing to some people though, right?
Because I mean, I think your music sounds fucking amazing,
but for some people they want to hear an actual sanding of a guitar,
the wrap of a drum, the, you know,
like people have this like very narrow ideas. Music is, is true. And,
uh, you know, I,
I think that there's two layers to two,
like electronic music, you know, you have to first of all make the music.
So you're, you're, you are making the music in one form or another with,
and I don't actually don't use like live instrumentation so much,
but sometimes I do. And um, because I come from that world,
it's natural for me to bring a guitar in, but it's not necessary. You know,
everything can be made from a laptop.
You don't even actually need very much anymore.
What can make you can make like a garage or something. Yeah.
I garage band I guess would be the rudimentary phone. Do you use
windows? Do you use a Mac? I use, uh, um, Apple, um,
Ableton live and uh, that's Ableton live as a software. Yeah.
So like the doll that I use to create the music, but you know,
you can literally, you don't even need a keyboard. You don't even need a mouse.
Well, if you really, you just need a hard drive of samples or you know,
having enough that you can build off of and your keyboard becomes,
you know, you know how,
how you're going to paint your notes in so you can make it that streamline if
you want it to. Now having like this big studios, it's great.
And I have a really beautiful studio in my house,
but it's more about the energy of the room for me.
Like I want to go in there like going,
I'm going to work 12 hours and I want to be excited to do that all the way until
whatever time.
It's that Las Vegas Vegas effect of being in a club or being in a casino and you
don't know what time it is.
I want that same effect in my room to be like energized and also energized
people that come in. But if I'm on the road, like, you know,
making an idea and just like strip lining it, I don't really need much,
you know? And I think that's like the setup right there. Oh yeah. Dude,
what a fucking bad ass room.
So I'll call a carpet. Yeah, I call it when I want that. It's a,
you know, blue, obviously my, my book's called blue, uh,
is my favorite color and I want the, the, the feeling to feel,
uh, futuristic. So it's the neon future cave. Now,
if you look up at the ceiling, if you scroll up in that picture, whatever, uh,
you'll get to see, maybe it's not in that picture, but I have, yeah,
so you have like these like led lights coming through the ceiling as if you're
in like a cave. And um,
and then you're looking at everything in this enormous projection screens that
what that is. Yeah. And it's, and it seats a ton of people. So, you know,
just, I mean, I'm releasing my,
my next singles with the Backstreet boys so I can fit all the Backstreet boys
skies in my house and my studio and we can, you know,
do what we do. Have you always lived in Vegas? Um,
I moved to Vegas in 20.
I bought my house in 2013. What made you move to Vegas? Um,
I was living in LA and my career broke in Los Angeles,
so there's no doubt about it being in LA for, as a musician, as an artist,
someone in music. That's where you, if you want a break,
you can have all the connections and build your network here fastest than
anywhere else. In the world. New York, I feel like is the media hub or fashion.
And then LA is as a music hub. And then Atlanta is like the hip hop hub,
Nashville's country. Um,
but I broke in LA and when I started touring 2009,
10, 2008, nine, 10, 11, I was just gone.
I started, I wasn't like living in LA the way I lived in LA,
going out to all the places that I love to eat,
all the culture of what LA offs offer.
I was only there 50 days of the year maybe. So I was like, well,
just sign a residency to in Las Vegas. Um,
when the nightlife boomed for DJs and from 2010,
it was a big shift of, of what nightlife has to offer in Vegas.
And DJs were a big part of that. And I signed a, you know,
a big residency deal and then I was like, I,
I mean I'm here more than I am in LA and uh,
you know, it's a good tax situation there. Um, there's no state tax there.
And, um, I'd have to leave LA, my, my home turf, but I'm not even there. Right.
So I just moved ship entirely bought a house,
bought the dream situation house. That's another, like,
there's so many perks for me because LA,
I had like a 2020 500 square foot, maybe 3000 square foot house,
which was nice million dollar house in the Hills.
And that's when I finally made it before I lived in an apartment on DeLong,
prenatal central, uh, East Hollywood, I guess Hollywood and vine area,
$900 for 900 square feet. That's where it all started for me.
That's when I first moved to LA and started making money.
It took time to get there. I kind of talk about that in the book,
like the hardships to get there because, um,
one of the best lessons that my father, uh,
shared with me was this tough love attitude where, you know,
he was a very rich, flamboyant restaurant tour.
Benihanas had fancy cars, was very flashy, very American.
Uh, he's the one that broke through the American dream. The, the Japanese,
the one of the few Japanese people that actually did that. So he's just like,
yo, look at me with, you know, hot flying, hot air balloons, uh,
offshore boat racing and, and then like, you know,
I guess the traditional thing is like the, he would financially help me,
you know, because he has the money to do that.
But one of the most powerful things he did was he just financially,
he didn't financially help me and I had to figure though my issues,
my hardships, my business plans, my, uh,
financial issues that I was going through on my own. So I had to start there.
And because of that, I was able to succeed through some of the hard stuff and,
and have that drive to want to make money for myself.
So during that time in LA, you know, I'm kind of digressing here. Uh, you know,
I lived in this apartment for about seven years and then,
um, the deejaying, my first priority of my record label, that was like,
why I moved to LA, sign artists, develop them, help them.
And then I was deejaying,
building the brand of the label and we created a really cool scene in LA and we
were breaking some of the biggest acts, not breaking where we were.
We were the underground hot bed, you know,
like let's say like the comedy shop or something where like everyone would hang
out. So like lady Gaga was playing for free at our shows.
Scrillex was there every single week. Um, we'll,
I am was dancing in the corner and then going back to the studio making black
IPS hits because 2007 through 2009 black IPS were the biggest artists.
LMF fail was there every single week. This is,
and then they became the biggest acts.
So we're like this hotbed of music culture in LA, but it was by parties. Wow.
And, and then that's how I, you know,
made a name for myself is that I was throwing these parties and I was deejaying
them, but no one cared that I was deejaying them.
The only reason why they were going is because these acts would always be there
and then the celebs would come in. You know, that's when I met DJ am in 2006,
2005 and then we got together and he brought the celebs in.
So now like there's a spotlight of pre TMZ kind of like, Oh,
what's going on over here with this electro sound with what you have,
like daft punk, their unmasked and uh,
and like really cool underground like kid Cuddy there and Connie West coming
through.
And then there's Lindsay Lohan and Paris Hilton and all these different people
all like in this small room.
And people wanted to know what the hell is going on in the,
in that little space. And this is what's,
what's great about this time was that it was pre uh, Snapchat,
pre social media. It was just my space.
So you had to be in that room to experience what was happening.
So people would fly in to just be in that room to hear what was the cutting edge
sound that was going to be eventually popular. You know,
people wanted to play in that little 300, 400 cap room.
Did you film any of that? There was always one guy filming.
I mean that's a thing because back then there was no phones that could film was
like razors and you know, like, like blackberries, you know,
you just can't get kicks. Yeah. It's like, it's the worst quality.
So a guy who has to bring a cam quarter in, right. And this one guy,
Glen Jaman, he would always film those parties, would have Cobra snake. My,
he was my best friend who would just run with me to all the shows and parties.
Uh, cause back then I would play like five nights a week in LA. And, um,
and he would photograph and he would document.
And that's how you'd find out about the lifestyle, the, the,
the clothes like this, the look of, you know,
what it was to be on Coalinga and Hollywood and that whole, you know,
and then you see kid Cuddy there and you'll see Connie West there and you'll
see, you know, whoever else that was just like hanging out,
absorbing the culture that we're, that we're like creating there. And,
uh, and then eventually that was what got me out of my debt bubble.
That was, you know,
cause I was a pretty bad businessmen when I was running and good luck.
I thought I was doing shit right. Uh,
because I signing acts that actually mattered and were taking off,
but I just didn't know how to, you know, I was just spending spending like, yo,
keep going with this and then, uh, you know, this are bringing the right people.
And I was like, okay, I need to build a team. I need to build some
people that have some sensibilities in this world. One creative.
And then the deejaying just took off as I was getting more into production,
getting more to remixing, getting more into, uh, creating myself as an artist.
And then that is what people know about me now. But really it was,
people knew about me because of the DIMOC and, and it's, uh, it's,
it's interesting how sometimes the evolutions of the errors of who you are,
you know, have changed over time. Um, and then, you know,
fast forward 2013 is when I was like, okay,
I got, yeah LA help grow me to who I am, my management,
my label, there's still LA, you know, um,
but Steve Aoki is going to be Las Vegas.
So I would love to see a documentary on that to see the,
that would be an amazing film. Like to see how that all was going down.
Right. You know, like if you have video footage,
did you get somebody to edit that and put together a documentary of that time
period? Cause it's a really interesting time period. Yeah. You know, for the,
the creation of electronic music and what you pointed out that's so interesting
was that 2010 was really somewhere around the time Vegas started becoming these,
these electronic music shows started taking precedent.
They're the biggest fucking thing.
I was staying at the Wynn recently and uh,
the hotel room we were at was overlooking the pool and I forget who it was that
was playing there, but it was fucking chaos.
And like you don't, and especially when you're, you know,
we're all like above like high above looking down on the pool,
we'll tell room for inside of you. It was so crazy.
It was so loud and so crazy and there was everybody's in the pool.
It was fucking madness. And you go on, this never existed.
I mean that's true to Vegas for a long time. This is a new thing.
It is a new thing over the last nine years. Exactly. And it's overtaken Vegas.
Everywhere you go,
there's these gigantic billboards with either your face on it or whatever.
Other DJs in this place and who's the guy with a fucking marshmallow head?
Is a guy a marshmallow that's marshmallow. Yeah. Okay.
That's like the unknown comic that's got a Marsh ball on his head.
But there's so many that I didn't even know who that was.
Like my kids were explaining to me,
my 11 year old was explaining to me marshmallow. I'm like,
how the fuck do you know who Marshall doesn't? And we're there and it's just,
it's everyone that's going out in Vegas.
But it used to be Vegas used to be like a cultural weird void.
Yeah, right. You would have some big acts that would come through there,
but it always seemed like they were at the end of their run. Right? Yeah.
You had to be at the end of your run. Yeah.
Like when Michael Jackson was considering doing Vegas, I was like, okay.
He's like finally saying that this the right, or you know,
it's like you see how to like Celine Dion, you know,
she did a residency in Vegas. You're like, ah, she's probably just tired.
Donny Marie. Yeah. Perfect. Manilow Barry Manilow, you know,
like carrot top does a residency there. I mean, he's doing really well.
It's not, it's not a knock. Yeah, no, it's not. It's really not. But it's,
that's what it was.
But then all of a sudden they became electronic music and it's like, wow,
what is happening? Like the, you know, these things are enormous.
Like there's so much bigger than any other kind of event that you have in Vegas,
other than like massive sporting events like [inaudible] or something. Yeah.
Well, it definitely, it's, it's provoked by energy too, you know, like,
and it's, and that's infectious. Yes. Well it's a fucking great time.
Like if you go to see Barry Manilow or you know,
whatever who have no knock on them, but you know what I'm saying, it's like,
I'm sure it's fine. It's mellow. It's like whatever you're into,
but when you're seated, you know,
like you're seated for a reason cause you're there to like sit and just enjoy.
Yes. At a,
there's no seats at a Steve Aoki show there are there like the tables and stuff,
but no one's sitting down. Right. That's the, that there'll be strange to see.
So unless there was passed out drunk or something,
but for the most part everyone's standing and jumping and being part of the
moment and that's, that's my job. Yeah.
I need to make sure everyone's attention is on me and then I'm taking them to
this next level. I've always wondered what it's like to live in Vegas though.
Like I've never lived there in my, you know,
my good friend Dana white lives there. He loves it there. He's,
he raves about it, but I've always liked Vegas. Okay. So
me, so I'm an LA guy, right? Like my heart and like, you know,
I love Los Angeles. I know LA so well.
And you know with LA you have your limitations. It's Los Angeles. You,
you can't like, if you want to build your dream house,
you cannot have a lot of money to do that. In Vegas.
When I moved there in 2013 I got a sick deal.
I bought my house at 16,000 square feet. Whoa.
2.8 million I think. Two point. Yeah. 2.8 it was a short sale.
Has a total steal. I mean like the guts were not good.
Like it was like one of those like prop homes almost.
So I had to Regan like I spent like 5 million into the house and it was more
about building my own dream house as I would want to have it.
I have a foam pit in there with a trampoline room. I have, I, I, I,
the pool in my backyard was too far away from my house.
So I filled it in and I built a pool at 16 feet deep right next to my,
um, uh, patio as 20 feet up.
I built the patio out so that way I can jump into the pool from, from the top.
And I'm like kid and basically a big kid. Um,
and I just think about how I want to make my house fun,
interactive for the artists that come there for me. Uh,
I have a S I've a fun gym. I've, you know,
I got my own like chest station, backgammon station, have a poker room,
you know. Um, it's,
it's the most hospitable house, you know, and I have all this space.
I have like a big shoe room. I'm big shoe collector.
I got this crazy library with books and records, you know, and I've,
I've a Bruce Lee mirror room, a mirror room. It's my closet,
but it's just like you walk in and it's like led strips everywhere with mirrors
and you know, I'm just having fun. I'm having fun with my house.
There is a mirror room. I have some really crazy, really beautiful RA,
but I got this amazing Banksy piece. Um, and so, you know,
I've been starting to collect art. There's my shoe remote.
So you get mad if people buy shit. Well, I bought it from him. Oh, you met him.
Tell us what he looks like. He is a, he's a girl. Ooh,
I'm just kidding. I never met him, but uh, I, you know, I,
I got into through is some people to get into,
cause he definitely a real person. Uh, you know, I don't know how Brown is that.
Yeah. It's someone in 2019 is managed to stay that secretive and really kind of
amazing. Credible because he's a cultural phenomenon. Yeah. I mean he's,
I mean everybody knows who Banksy is. Yeah. Right. Or you know,
of young C I should say, but no one knows who he is, which is crazy.
Who the fuck has ever pulled that off, right.
Unique human being. Yeah, it's true. How does that work?
How does not sure do that? I think you have, I mean it's, it's like his,
he's always seen me to find a way to troll people in a social or political
critique. Um, just like he did with, uh, the, um,
the art sale of, of the shredded painting Yas. How amazing was that? Yeah,
that was pretty crazy. Yeah.
But watch those people after they paid it and see the, the thing me dropped out.
But I'll read though. Let me ask you this though.
I don't want to go too deep into this,
but because I don't know if I'm like stepping on anyone's toes here, but
if this is really Selfridges or you know, like a real auction house,
aren't they gonna look at the painting or the piece,
are they going to open up the frame and make sure there's not some weird drill
going through? Like I think they would ever expect that to be the case. I mean,
but your but your and your antique, you should be checking everything,
making sure everything's authentic now. Well,
if it's an authentic piece and it somehow or another,
some reliable source brings it to them as an authentic piece.
They just accept the fact they don't check the details of the piece.
I mean what can they do? Wow. By the way,
I'll take that and fucking glue that bitch back together again.
Leave it that way. You want to like that?
That's like what makes the value is that you like to actually have it hanging
there. That's why you want it in your house. Really. You want it just like that?
Yeah. Look at the people's face. Sometimes. I forget that I'm on the phone.
Oh no. Oh no. Thurston we've lost the piece.
Yeah. You know, I, I wish like,
it's funny that we're talking about this cause sometimes I forget like,
you know, we were having a chat and uh, I realize,
Oh there's a lot of people listening in on this so maybe I should give away some
of the stuff that I've learned about it. But, um, yeah. Anyways,
I'll leave it there. Well he's a definitely unique human. Yeah.
So let's get back to Vegas so you don't feel weird living there.
Cause the one thing that I've felt about Vegas is I always enjoy going there and
enjoy leaving more. I'm like gimme home give me,
well that's because you go there with that intention. Like for me,
I built my compound, right? So it is home. It's 100% home. It's,
it's exciting to be home.
And the best part about it is like first I built the compound,
this dream house to invite. Like all my friends,
I'm a hospitable guy so I like I want artists that come there.
My friends would come there,
stay there with me in a family and the next best thing was calling my mom and my
sister who lived together and I said, will you move to Vegas?
Will you be in my neighborhood? And they said yes.
And that was the best money I spent was by my mama house. And they, you know,
like they live around the corner.
My mom was cooking like by the time I'm home I see my mom all the time and I
never had the opportunity.
We had this 10 plus year gap where I see her like once every six months because
I'm just touring like a beast right now. I just see my family a lot more,
you know, like so in a way I'm trying to bring my family all to Vegas.
My cousins moved from uh,
from the East coast with his wife and his mom to Vegas, you know,
before even my mom. So I have my, my cousin there, I, my mom,
my sister there with their daughter. Uh,
my brother Kevin who is a restaurant tour as well.
He's planning to make the move cause we're going to open up some restaurants on
the strip.
Dan did you got your fingers in a lot of pies and on that pie note I do have
pizza Aoki. Yes I do. I have 19 kitchens now. Whoa. Yeah,
it's been about about a year and two months and we're growing at a rapid rate.
And I would imagine 19 and 19, 19 kitchens of the year,
most of them are in Los Angeles because that's, you know,
like that's where we kind of broke ground and we were just like opening up
kitchens and all the areas that that a Postmates was giving us information like,
yo, this is where it makes sense to do that. So we work with all the, the uh,
delivery hubs and uh, mostly delivery thing or do you yeah,
I do have two dining locations, but the whole business model is about delivery.
Really. Yeah. It's all about delivery and uh,
that way my costs are very low and then, um,
I could be effective. Like I'm not really spending much money on marketing. And,
and what's funny is,
is that people love to post pizza and pizza Oakey is a pretty fun concept.
Dude. Fight companion. Pete's Aoki Saturday, let's make it happen. I'll,
we'll send as many pizza cookies you guys need.
Like whenever you want a live fight companion for the UFC this Saturday it'd be
like 11:00 AM in the morning cause it's in ABI Dhabi. So, uh, we'll hit it up.
I'll make that happen. Yeah. Alright. What kind of pizza you got man? Oh,
we got all kinds of pizzas. But most importantly,
you know the F the idea of pizza Oki might sound like a gimmick and you're like,
okay, I'll try it out.
But 60% of the people or in PCO return,
so we know that it's quality. You know,
imagine that you're doing anything half-assed. No, I don't think so. Do you,
do you get, you don't,
so you have a established essentially like created your own world in Vegas.
So everyone's there that you know, and you can stick the thing about Vegas,
right as like the allure of the strip,
but you're kind of removed from that anyway. You don't do drugs,
you don't drink. Right. You don't fuck around with anything. No. Yeah.
That's like one of the things that we've taught, like,
you know when we talked about how I'm sustainable is that you,
you have to not do the certain things that make it unsustainable. Right?
So I never really got into drugs. I do talk about my book,
my first acid trip when I was 13 but that scared the living shit out of me to
stay away from anything hallucinogenic and like literally you got 13 so I just
stay away from drugs. That's a bad time to do acid. It's a very,
very funny story. But I'm sure it got to the point where I just became this,
this uh, straight edge hardcore kid.
I became extremely religious because I was in this like I was 13 I was looking
up going, I'm going to be fucked for the rest of my life.
Like when you're on acid, you're like fucking out there.
You're just so fucked up. And, and when you start thinking like,
this is how I'm going to be forever,
you're clinging on to anything that can get you out. Right. And for me,
when I grew up as a kid,
my mom was putting me into like Catholic schools and one of the best thing that
Catholic schools do is indoctrinate kids on fear. And so,
you know like you know,
I remember going up to the drawing board like there was like a a drawing of what
hell is like, guess who's going there forever. People that don't believe,
you know,
and you know when you're young you start seeing that and then when you get into
a place of vulnerability where you're like, where I was,
I was like scared shitless. I was like,
I'm going to go to an insane award when I'm 13 because I can't get out of this
acid held trip. How long did it last? I guess like what?
78 hours. But every second is like a minute, you know,
cause you cannot sleep, you cannot stop thinking about what you're in.
I mean there is like, it's like this exaggerated emotions.
Like the first part of my acid trip was like, I was so funny.
I was laughing at everything. It was like the best thing I ever did. I was like,
Oh my God, everything is so funny. I'm laughing.
I'm like in pain cause I'm like, so just laughing at everything.
Just everything is joyous.
And then like I went into this upside down world,
like stranger things when I got dropped off at my friend's house and everyone
went dark and my friends were my friends. 14 he doesn't do drugs.
So he was just in, his mom was come down, you're okay. Everything's okay.
He didn't know you want to ask them? No, they knew I was on acid,
but they're like, you're like, I'm like a 80 pound Japanese kid,
you know, five foot, you know, like a little kid.
Like what the hell am I doing acid for? You know,
I do talk about like where that came out. But um, yeah, so like when I was,
when I got flipped in that world, then everything was like,
I saw street fighter, like fireballs from rye. You coming at me,
like when I closed, when I closed my highs, it was very,
very vibrant and fitted. And I mean, it was,
it's a trip for sure. So once you regain sanity,
you're like enough of any of this nonsense. Once I was like, Oh, why God,
I'm back, this is, this is for real. Like I, I have fucked drugs.
Fuck this shit. You know, like, and then I was like,
I'm straight edge cause that's the music I was starting to get into.
And then I was like, I'm all about God and Jesus,
it's going to save me, you know, like he saved me.
So like as a kid I was very religious going, um, Allen and that, you know,
start exploring more about the world and,
and then when more from this face or faith-based concepts of living through life
to, you know, things that needed me more, I needed to make sense for me.
Um,
I'm very much more scientific on like the understanding of how I want to see
things. Where, where did the change take place? When did it take place? Uh,
that would happen to be college and post.
Where'd you go to school? UC Santa Barbara. So when you went was great air.
I love Santa Barbara. God, it's like the hidden gem of California, right? Yeah.
So sweet out there. Yeah.
So you just became educated,
started learning more about things and then, so yeah,
I don't know if there was like one spark that happened.
It was just kind of like, I just had questions about why things happen.
Like w what, what is religion? Like what, you know,
you know, how things work in the world, how societies are built. Um,
did you study theology? A little? A little,
but I don't know if that would be like the philosophy classes I was taking was
not really the, the crux of it. Sociology was my major.
I was women's studies and sociology when I was in college. Women's studies.
Yeah. W I would want, yeah, I want to say them out. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
the bottom of this, I have to say like, strangely enough,
that's the first thing you think about, right? Why?
Why is the guy in women's studies, let's try to understand.
I mean,
the reason why I was in that department is because my favorite teachers,
uh, were the teaching those classes.
So I just was like, all right, I'll try this one. And then I was like, wow,
this is actually pretty interesting. I'll try another one. And um,
and then I was like, well, I'll just,
I'll finish off the nature [inaudible] and uh, you know,
I'd have to say like the stuff that I learned in school,
it's in large part of how I kind of looked through,
kind of like navigate through my life. Like sociology. I am a sociologist,
I want to study people like why they do certain things, you know,
like how do I navigate them in different directions? Well,
and then you've become a purveyor of great fun.
Like that's essentially what you do professionally, right? I mean,
you give people a great time. Like your shows are this wild,
extremely energetic experience for people and they leave.
There is a certain level of transformants right? You know,
I've watched some of your shit online and you do these enormous crowds,
man,
and it's so Epic and you see all those people going fucking crazy and dancing
along to your shit. I mean, it's gotta be a wild,
wild feeling knowing that you're giving this really positive experiences.
Thousands and thousands of people that are just roaring along to your music
while yeah, no, as you say, I'm like, you know, getting all like goosebumps.
Yeah, I know. Cause it is exactly what you're saying and that's why, um,
I guess you could say I'm addicted to that and because I care so much about that
I have to be sustainable. You know, it goes back to what we were talking about.
Like what do I need to do as you do too.
There's no fucking way you could do 250 shows a year and get fucked up 250 days.
Oh yeah. Cause there's a lot, you know, in that business especially, you know,
the business of electronic dance music, there's a lot of people doing Molly,
right?
There's a lot of people doing all kinds of amphetamines and all kinds of crazy
shit. And you got to think like you do that every night, man.
You're going to look like an 80 year old man by the time you're 40 years old
because you've literally burned the candle with a blow torch.
You've used that Elon Musk not a flame fucking fucked up candle, you know,
I mean it's,
but you know what I always say if whenever I have the opportunity is that for
the people in my crowds and I have to say country by country,
they're very different as far as like what I think if they're doing drugs or
not. Where did they do the most drugs? No, I don't think so.
I don't, but you know it's hard. It's like I'm just judging. Right.
I don't know like what people are doing out there.
I could judge by how interactive they are. That's the best way I can tell.
Right. If they're like, yeah, if their that's the worst.
That's the worst subject to play too.
It's like literally playing at a cocktail party when their backs are turned to
you is the same kind of thing for me.
So if they're already high and they just like lost it in their world,
like it's no fun for me. Plus I spend so much
time making like my set so interactive,
so engaging and entertaining. Like it's a bit disrespectful.
Yeah, it all. But like, you know, some people are going to do it.
You're not going to be like the Debbie downer and be like, yo, everyone,
all drugs get the hell outta here. You lose 80% of the crowd.
You said that everyone on drugs at the front guy, they listened to you.
What percentage do you think in Vegas would leave? Oh God, I don't know.
I don't know. I don't even want it. I don't even want to know.
I don't even want to know honestly. I's weed weeds different though.
Weeds more like chill, you know, like,
but if you're so like high zonked off your head where you can't,
you don't even know where you are, what's going on,
then like you just lose the whole experience. I mean,
a lot of the times people wake up, well, what happened? Well, I mean,
what's the point of, of uh, you know, all of the experience. If you,
you're so blitzed out of your head, you don't even know what's going on.
So allegedly during the experience or having a good time at it. Yeah. Yeah.
But I mean that's, it's a really wonderful way to make a living. It's the,
it's like literally the dream come true, you know, to make people happy,
get to be, I always say like,
I feel like I'm the chef in the kitchen making the food and I go out and I get
to watch people eat my food and then they're like, Oh, this is really good.
I'm like, I'm like, yes. You know? Like, I, since I see that feeling,
I'm like, let's go back and make more food,
but we got to sprinkle more truffle on that and then let's deliver it and I get
a C and then they're like, you're the, you're the chef. Like that's me.
You know? So like, it's like I get that luck,
lucky position to be able to make my music and then share it and hope that they
have the same feeling that I have sharing it.
So how many shows do you do in Vegas and how many shows do you do abroad? Uh,
around 40 in Vegas. So two 10 40 a year. 40 year.
So how do you, when do you there? Like, how do you, do you still have residency?
You just were at a Hawk, Hassan Omnia um, jewel,
smaller club of theirs and uh, and what Republic.
So there's four properties that I play,
which is nice cause if I had to play 40 shows in one,
I mean it wouldn't necessarily be that bad because the thing about Vegas is a
transient crowd, right? So it's always no matter what,
even on one weekend I might be playing possibly three or four times for one
weekend. Right. And every show I do, whether it's a day party in a club,
the club is a complete different influx of people coming in because the people
that saw me at the day party are going to go see Chainsmokers or marshmallow or
you know, whoever else or Calvin Harris or whatever is playing out on the strip.
The competition is as thick as it gets every night.
There's the biggest DJs playing alongside, you know, each other.
It's really amazing.
If you stop and think about what a crazy change that to an entertainment
environment like the Vegas,
the transformation to that electronic music around, like you said,
2010 there's not a thing like that that you can point to anywhere else in the
world where like all of a sudden this one dominant form of entertainment has
taken over the entire nightlife of a city. Right. Other than a big,
some sort of big event that's in Vegas,
the fucking rodeo or the UFC or something like that where everybody comes in to
see that you guys are what's up?
I mean that is what's up in Vegas. It's the, it dominates it. What,
how did that happen? That's a crazy thing. It really is. Yeah.
When you say it like that, I'm like, no one had place.
Like if you go to New York, if you go to LA, if you go to all, all places,
all around the world,
there's no other thing that has transformed the nightlife of a city.
The way electronic music has transformed Vegas transformed, changed.
Everything went from non-existent to number one with a bullet.
Like there's not even a close second. It's all electronic music.
Anthony Bordain used to hate it. It was hilarious. He's the Quito.
He was like [inaudible]. It was old and crotchety.
He'd be at these places and all the music and he just wasn't his thing.
But he still was in awe of how that guidance.
I love that guy. I never met him, but he was awesome. Yeah, I miss them.
Yeah. There's a plenty of people that that do go to Vegas or like,
Oh this is so annoying.
Just kids running around like kids. But like young adults running around,
you know, especially the day like in their bikini's running. I mean, I,
I suppose probably people would like that, but in any case it's uh,
yeah.
It's also different for the casino operators because they're dealing with this
younger generation of people too and they have to think differently about how
they're going to get them to, you know, deal what Degas has meant to be.
You know, what the economy is serving. Gambling. Yeah.
Well they're paying to see you as well. And alcohol sales as well.
I think alcohol sales have become a large, large portion of their revenue.
Right. I think that like, I could be wrong here,
but the gambling side is actually smaller portion than the everything else.
I think that's true. I think that's shifted.
I've read something about that recently that entertainment has become the
primary revenue source in Vegas, whereas it used to be gambling. Right.
But it's, you know, there's, there's still gambling, but boy,
it's hard to just convince young people to start gambling.
It's easy to convince them to start dancing, you know? Yeah. It's like,
it seems normal. It's natural. There's also, when you're young,
you don't have the money to just risk,
but you have the money to go and like experience fun. Yes. Yeah. You know,
like when you're older you're like, okay, I can, I have some of like flexible
income streams I can put down on some blackjack or whatnot.
I would have loved to seen the Sinatra days like Vegas when it was run by the
mob. I'd love to see what those, like the rat pack and say, yeah, he was junior.
I just would love to have been in the room and watch,
watched one of those shows and then you know,
come to today and see how things have changed.
I mean I think that's like the Bourdain thing.
Like he had been there when he was young and then see it change now. Right.
But I am fascinated by change. I don't resist it and uh, I don't,
I don't say Oh the good old days. That don't mean shit to me.
I am absolutely on the same page as you. Yeah. I'm, I'm interested in, I'm yeah,
I'm always interested in the next thing. I want to try the next thing. Yeah.
And you know, you want to enhance your experience.
You want to enhance what you're doing to make it serve you better.
But if you went to someone in like 1985 and said, Hey man, guess what?
2019 electronic music, cause when you do this shit,
that's going to be everywhere. People would go, what are you talking about?
Get this guy out of here, man. There's a wall. There's one,
one guy that did say that though, who? Jim Morrison did. He really? Yeah.
So like he did a prediction. It's like somewhere, I'm sure you can find it,
but he did a prediction where whenever he was alive, I guess,
I guess I would probably back in 76, 60 or 70.
So he said like the future will be one,
one person with some sort of computer or something. Uh,
it was that's going to be devised electronically or something like that.
And that one person will be making music for people and,
and performing that now. Oh, we'll watch a video. So yes,
I remember this now. Yeah. So I, I forgot what he said,
but he said something to that effect and it's like,
it's crazy cause I was what 50 years ago, take it from the beginning.
Indigenous to this country are uh, the, uh,
black music blues and the kind of folk music that was brought over from Europe
and it would,
I guess they call it country music or that kind of West Virginia high lonesome
sound that those,
those are the two main streams of root American music.
There might be others I don't have, but, uh,
like 10 years ago with they called rock and roll was kind of a blending of those
two forms, I guess in four or five years. Uh, the new
generations music will be, um, it'll have, uh,
a synthesis of those two elements in some third thing. It'll be entire.
Maybe it'll be, uh, it might rely heavily on, uh,
uh, electronics tapes. I can kind of envision maybe, um,
one person with a, uh, a lot of machines,
tapes and electronic setups, uh, uh,
singing or speaking and using machines.
Yes. From what his mindset is of what he can consider is what that would be.
It's, you know,
he did prints, you know, he did predict. Yeah. I mean,
near where it is, you know, like,
I think that's what happens when you do acid correctly.
You get those sort of visions. Yeah. Because I mean, also Jim Morrison,
like you can tell he's, he's such an artist that, you know,
he could, after the doors, you'd just be himself. Yeah. You know,
he would have done a Jim Morrison album where he's made all the music,
he's done everything. He would be exactly what he's saying.
He's basically predicting what he would have, in my opinion,
what he would become. And he was probably like 25 in that video,
which is even crazier. Yeah, I mean, died at 27 that's, that's crazy. Nuts,
nuts. I mean,
that whole era of the 1960s fascinates me to no end.
I love the cars. I love the sound. To this day,
most of the music I listened to is classic rock. I mean,
I listened to a lot of new stuff, but man,
I will pull out some fucking classic rock. I love it. I love listening to it.
There's something about it that makes me,
just makes me realize what a profound change it was between the 1950s and 1960s
that's the culture exploded, that something happened, something happened,
and the, the,
the clothes and the music and the sounds and the fucking muscle cars,
like everything went haywire.
Like you went from 1950 to 1916 just a radical shift.
Right? So many great artists, you know, Hendricks and yeah,
the whole idea of like, like, okay,
now it's time to experiment and to free ourselves from the confines of what
like, you know, it's been posted. Yes. Yeah. Right. The doors wide open.
I think buddy Holly was great. I love buddy Holly.
But if you go from buddy Holly to Hendrix, you're like, what?
What happened? You know, that's what acid trip actually goes, right?
Like you're saying, apparently they said he used to put acid in his bandana.
I dunno if that's true,
but that it would seep into his skin as he was pulling down.
He's just like letting his guitar on fire and picking with his teeth.
Man. How much would you love to watch that guy live? Oh yeah. Oh,
that was been incredible.
To be in the presence of something completely unique. You know,
this hippie black dude who's the greatest guitarist of all time,
still still like there's no one.
Like there's some amazing guys today, Gary Clark jr. and of course,
you know Stevie Ray Vaughn was amazing. There's a bunch of great,
amazing guitars all sudden. The showmanship though, you know the outfits,
like it's like all of the combined, not just his, his technical ability,
the fact that he was doing these, these things that you're like, you know,
some of that guitars won't, wouldn't do that. That's not part of their like,
you know, protocol. But he was just like on another world.
Yeah. And did to be a part of that, you know, see that. That's incredible.
A complete outlier. Yeah, yeah. Yes. And again,
like no one was like that before that and like go to the 1940s it's only 20
years. Yeah. 40 is only, I mean 20 years ago is, you know,
we're dealing with, you know, 1999 that's,
that doesn't seem that long ago. Yeah.
But 69 to 49 you might as well be from another world.
Yeah. You really might as well be my, I might as well be another planet.
So what do you think was one of the bigger cultural shifts of why that happened?
Simply hundred percent. Hundred percent. Yeah. I mean,
obviously when we talk about Jimmy Hendrix and the Beatles and the beach boys,
like whoever else is like, yeah, yeah, yeah. The doors, Joplin drugs. Yeah.
Drugs, the doors, drugs. Right. Everyone. Drugs. They were,
they were taking mind expanding psychedelics and the culture had shifted to
embrace these mind expanding psychedelics.
And there was also the resistance to the Vietnam war.
There's this rebellious movement. There was these young,
compassionate people that were trying to figure their way through life in a way
that didn't resonate with the way their parents had set boundaries and
standards. And they wanted out of all of it, that Goldwater Republican shit.
They will,
they wanted to be free and flower children and hippies and then Woodstock and
all that craziness, you know? Yeah.
And what's amazing is how quickly it ended. You know,
so many things came around.
Some of the things came along and that scared people, you know, like, you know,
at the end of the day, like when,
when they're dropping at 27 your heroes, Morrison,
Janis Joplin, Hendrix, all 27 and, and like,
they're the leaders of this experimental revolution. Yup. Not good.
That's going to end things pretty quick. I think there was that,
there was also the sweeping psychedelic act of 1970 that made everything
schedule one and they were locking people up in jail.
They were also passing laws directly was there was a civil rights movement was
happening at the same time and they were passing laws that were directly
targeting the people in the civil rights movement because they knew that they
were smoking grass and they were and doing mushrooms. Right.
So they were going after them with these drug laws and then, you know,
they would arrest one person, they would turn on everybody else and then,
you know, they'd do like mob tactics people and yeah, the whole thing.
They just poured water on it. It took, you know,
it took like 10 or 20 years before shit started popping again. You know,
in terms of like the influence of a psychedelic culture. Again,
really more like 30 years, you know,
it's like the two thousands where things started happening again or people
started becoming more and more aware of the positive benefits of psychedelic
drugs and ultra States of consciousness.
Not trying to escape reality,
but trying to get a grip on reality from a different perspective,
you know? But I think that's an like, like when I
think about psychedelics in that regard of mind expansion or you know,
we got at the same time, it's like this uncontrolled situation that like, okay,
we're going to jump into this world,
but there's no way to really control your lane. It's just like this. Yeah.
It's like, yes, we can go there. Well it might not end up,
you might get stuck there. That's my problem with that. You could get stuck,
you know? I mean like you, you hear the horror stories and that scares the hell.
Did you like sky is still on an acid trip for 25 years walking around that,
you know, thinking people are chasing him. Acid in particular. Yeah,
like shine on you
crazy diamond. And I think there's,
there's people that have a predisposition towards psychosis there.
There's certain people that have schizophrenia in there. Their journey,
their genes and their answer. And for those people it's very dangerous.
You know what else is very dangerous for those people? Edible marijuana.
Not just like what you think of as hardcore psychedelics,
but I've known a quiet,
quite a few people that have eaten edible marijuana and blown.
Wow. Yeah. There's something I, I I just recently did,
which is pretty exciting for me was um, you know,
once again the scientific information, I'm just gonna wing it, but I,
I tried this brain cap on, okay,
this has all these nodules like that can read the neurotransmitters in my brain
and it's connected to a computer. And uh, you,
you sit there for about a minute and you just, you, I kind of meditate on,
really focused on one, one thing. So it could start like reading your,
your brain, basically your, your neurotransmission signals. Um,
and uh,
it's kind of like neural feedback on steroids if you know anything about neural
feedback. Um, and, uh,
it gave me a list of, of categories of what I want to know about who I am.
I've, I, I always thought that I had a slight add.
I never was diagnosed cause I have like if, if Joe Rogan's boring me,
I might like turn over here, you know, like the, my invitation is normal. Yeah,
I know, right. But I was like,
I don't have that bad of add where I can't concentrate to get things done
because I get things done. But I do have,
I do think about a lot more things than I think I should. Maybe. So anyways,
I was, I did this test and it shows like your,
your signals coming and uh,
and it has all of these different things like anxiety, delusion, schizophrenia,
um, uh, you know, attention so forth, you know,
absolutely incredible. I was like, okay, I'm scared of press this button.
Schizophrenia. I'm really scared but I want to know.
So it gives you the feeling of being schizophrenia? No, no, no, no.
It shows your brain activity if you, if you have a tendency to be schizophrenia.
You were saying like there's a way for them kind like,
like do you want to feel what it feels? No, no, no. That's,
that's like in the future. But like, I want to see if like,
do I have the neural pathways
that, that a schizophrenia person would,
would you know how they would think about the world? Yeah. So, you know,
I clicked on that and I'm like, I'm good. You know, I'm good. Okay, good.
So what about um, delusion. Okay. Anxiety low. OK. So I,
I got a lot of information out of that.
So I guess the reason why I'm sharing that is that, you know,
you should try this out. You think it's something that,
that I think you'd be interested in. I am interested in. Yeah.
Do you know the name of the uh, well they, they flew to me just like I'm saying,
like I love to meet groups and organizations and research, uh,
researchers and scientists and these people you,
I was putting out to the world and they came, they flew all to me,
like some from Colorado. So I'm from Toronto and uh, and,
and they, they did this test on my head and my brain. Whoa. Yeah.
So I'll get you information on that,
try it out and see if it's something that's like interests you.
But I'm sure it will. I'm in. It's very exciting stuff. It sounds,
I hope I'm not crazy. Fuck, what do you do if you find out you're really insane
when I put the thing on you and they're like, dude, you're fart.
Results like this before you need to be locked up, then all sudden people come.
Well, you wouldn't even know it, right? If you're really crazy you like,
you think that like,
you know the five people are on the corner chasing after you.
They're always the real,
or maybe the beautiful mind guys to have a bit about the problem with dumb
peoples that they, they're too stupid to know they're dumb. So the thing,
everybody else is dumb. Yeah, that's a problem. Right? So if you're crazy,
you might think everybody's crazy, right? Even though, Oh yeah,
like the brain scan is making you crazy.
It's like you might think that everybody else is crazy, right?
And then you do the brain scan like, no, no, no, no, no. It's you. Yeah,
you're tricking me. You're, you're doing something to me.
Why have you ever met people that blame everyone else in their life?
For all their problems. Yes, sure. Yeah. And they can't see what we can see.
Yeah. You can see, Hey man, it's you. Yeah.
You are causing your problems. Yes. But yes,
you never are self critical. Yeah.
Looking externally for all of your issues,
you're criticizing everyone,
but you are the architect of your own demands and you don't even realize it.
I think that is one of the,
the the biggest problems for like why people are not finding their own success.
Yeah. You know,
because they keep blaming other people for problems when they could use that
same time to actually focus on a small success that's realistic in their
trajectory or whatever they're doing. Yeah. And I've seen that a lot with my,
you know, some people I know and just it's, they get stuck in that, that,
that framework and then there might be people that enable that same mindset.
Yeah. It's patterns as well.
Like sometimes people develop these defensive patterns in order to protect
themselves from reality. Right.
They put up these psychic shields to sort of protect themselves from self
critical ideas or externally critical ideas,
and they just don't want to deal with change. They don't,
they want to pretend that they're the fucking man. They're
the coolest. Did they get it? Everybody else is dumb and God,
it's such a toxic way to view the world and the people that have that view gain,
no traction, almost always fall apart. Yeah. It's just,
it's unsustainable. It's not a way to live your life. No. Yeah. It's,
it's fucking hard to see to, man, it's hard to see why.
If you know someone that's like that, you almost kinda got to go, fuck man,
I'm walking away. I can't help anymore. Yeah. Well, I think also for them,
they see the success of other people and they're like,
like they want to be that, but they're like, yeah. You know,
they obviously can't with,
they just blame everyone that they can't be that person. Right.
Instead of just like going,
well we got to take these small baby steps to get out of this funk and then
eventually, you know, stop comparing yourself to other people.
But compare yourself to your yourself. Yes. Look at yourself critically.
But I think another thing that's really important is to enjoy other people's
success instead of being jealous, which is a really common,
easy to understand sort of an emotional reaction to other people's success.
You what the best way to look at it. In my opinion,
the best way to look at is look at someone else doing amazing things and go,
fuck, this is amazing. What would they have done?
Be excited by it and then be inspired. Exactly.
You can use it as fuel in a positive way.
And then also there's no negative feeling like that person doesn't have to feel
like you're, you're fucking giving them the sour face cause you're, you're,
you're jealous and bitter and weird and you're looking to be critical of them
and find flaws in them. Look at what they're doing.
Like look at like if you were a guy who's coming up right and you wanted to be a
guy who makes electronic music and I'm sure you have haters. All my God,
they're lined up, lined up, I'm sure. Yeah. Why? Why do you have haters?
Because you're fucking awesome. That's why.
Because what you're doing is fucking awesome. So instead of saying, man,
this guy is inexhaustible. He's excited about what he's doing.
He's got a real passion for creating things. People love it.
And your attitude about making these shows and giving these people this amazing
time and how much focus and energy you put into it.
What I hate or should look at that and go this, I've got to do more of that.
I got to do more of that. I've got to give more.
But instead they try to poke holes. The music. Yeah. Fucking cakes.
[inaudible] that is a sore spot for people to, I'm sure. Yes.
Anything awesome as a sore sore spot for assholes. Yeah.
It's just nothing you can do about that. You just have to,
you got to keep on being you. But them their, their, their hell.
And their prison is that they're focusing on. Yeah. Yeah.
They're hating and focusing on, yeah, yeah, true words.
Yeah. It's, um, it's a weird world being an entertainer, isn't it? Yeah.
It's a different kind of lifestyle, you know? It's,
you know, I mean, actually the strange thing is when I think about like,
like fame or whatever celebrityhood uh, when I walk through certain areas,
I get like I have to just go, okay,
I have to accept the F the photos I have to accept. Like people coming up to me,
I want to be the asshole.
Cause I have been that kid going up to someone and they're mean to me.
And I'd be like, Oh, that guy's a Dick. You know,
I'll never think of you that way for us.
Even if you're just in a bad day or some, you know, you just,
the one that might be using me the most is people coming up to you while you're
eating. I had a guy come up to me right now,
last night in the middle of like literally cutting food and in a crowded
restaurant. Yeah.
And he's hovering over the table trying to get me to get up and take a photo.
I'm like, dude, what if I did that for everybody? Like what if I just, yeah,
right. That this is a ridiculous request. Yeah. Like you shouldn't do that.
Like, what did you say? Did you say that? Okay, let's take a picture.
We're in the middle of a meal. Not only that, we were in the middle,
it was Andrew Schultz, my buddy,
and we were in the middle of talking to this guy.
Just interrupted the conversation, wanted a picture. I was like,
there's a time and a place for it, right. If you want to say, Hey,
when you're leaving, can I get a picture? Sure. Yeah, sure. Yeah. Well,
you got a mouth full of food and you're cutting food and somebody could come on
and you can't interrupt meals.
There's a ridiculous that that happens to me all the time.
It's what stupid.
But you know what's really weird in LA doesn't have to be that much. Well, I,
people are more accustomed to seeing famous people. Yeah. And they're like,
I don't want to, you know, they just get it. They don't want to bug you as much,
but everywhere else, LA in New York,
I'm not really bothered as much everywhere else.
It's like it just says just going to, I just have to accept it,
but you can't interrupt people while they're eating. That is just one of those,
don't interrupt me when I'm meeting.
Don't interrupt me when I'm talking to my kids like this. This,
it's a stupid thing to do. You have to have manners.
You have to have some sort of a, a,
an understanding that this is a human being that is living their own life and
even though you're a fan of them, your being a fan does not take precedent. You,
you can't just, you, they don't owe you this, right?
You can't just interrupt their life and you shouldn't want that.
You shouldn't want to interrupt someone in the middle of a conversation in the
middle of the middle, in the middle of talking to their children.
It's a foolish way to interact with them. I remember one time I was,
you know, in a deep conversation,
just like you're talking about with someone outside of a, um,
casino about to leave and the sky's just drunk and he's just like,
like staring and like wobbling and like, you know,
doing his thing and I just see him hovering and I am not going to engage with
him. I'm just talking. And finally I'm like, Hey man,
I'm just in the middle of a conversation and you know, well,
I didn't say we'll get a photo later. I'm like, well,
I'll talk to you later because I didn't, I didn't want to like be presumptuous.
And, uh,
I got done with the conversation and he was just a very aggressive,
and I just, I just ran
and I remember I ran to my car and, um, I'm like,
I just don't want to get into this, you know, like, and he's chasing me.
Oh my God, he's chasing me. And just like, fuck you.
I was your fan and you feel like treated me like, shit,
this is how you treat your fans. I'm like, I'm like, Oh my God.
It's just too much. You know and like, and it stays with you. You know,
like even though I dunno, that's part of the problem with Vegas too.
People are at, it's that they're at new year's Eve level every night. Yeah.
You know that it's like a thing for new year's Eve.
I stopped doing shows a couple of years ago on new year's Eve cause every time I
would do them I was like,
why does everybody think it's okay to be an asshole tonight?
People want to heckle. They want to yell things out. I was like,
on new year's Eve, I'm just going to stay home. I'm going to hang out.
I'm not going to do shows. It just seems too chaotic.
It never feels that feels like a real show. Well, Vegas is like,
there's a lot of people that are running around like every night.
Like what happens in Vegas,
they just go and crazy. It's, it's such a wild place. It's a hall pass.
It's like, okay, we gotta go big. We're here 24 hour drinking, right? Yeah.
Free booze.
If you gambling like what a wacky thing we're going to give you a drug that
fucks up your decision making and then you're going to gamble everything you
have. How is that legal? How does that,
you can't really enormous sums of money and they're giving you alcohol. Right?
This is so crazy, but I love it. I love that it exists.
I love that there's a city where everything is kind of wild where everything is
like things are up.
Like I play pool and Vegas is one of the rare places where pool halls are 24
hours a day. So you could play pool till five o'clock in the morning,
six o'clock in the morning, you know, you,
and there'll be good players in there and you know,
people really appreciate pool and you know,
everything's 24 you can get good meals like really late at night.
That's for sure. Yeah. Yeah. So wild place, man. It really is. But you,
because you're a clean and sober guy, you avoid all the pitfalls.
Yeah. I think that's like how it works for me cause I, I'm not like,
I'm not a strip club guy. You know, I, I just, I don't, I,
I've learned my lesson on gambling. I guess that was like a gamble. I did play,
um, blackjack mainly.
And that's just the worst odds for you the most you've ever lost in the night.
Um, 50,
50 K Dana white told me lost 1 million bucks one night. Yeah.
I'm not at that level, but he won 7 million.
And then when he wants [inaudible] babies as far as like, kindness,
data's crazy. But they kicked him out of the casino.
They said he can't come back. Yeah. That's the problem actually.
When you like do well for yourself when the odds are stacked against you and
they kick you out,
that's crazy. Well, the crazy thing is he's just gambling.
He just happened to win. Like, what are we doing?
Is this really gambling or you're just stealing money from people?
What are you doing?
The guy won and they like where you're not allowed to play here anymore. Right.
You know, he's not stealing. He's Dana white. You know, he's rich. Yeah.
It's not, you know, he's just a gambler. Yeah. So this is like real gambling.
This is not like some guy with some sort of a scheme and it's cheating.
If someone's doing something with the car as actually gambling and you're mad at
him or mad cause you lost. Yeah, that's it.
That's the can just take you out following the rules. You can come back.
They'll ban you from the casino. I almost wish I was like,
can I get to that level? It's like, can I get there where I'm,
I've just won that much. Um, God man, but interested.
I don't gamble at all. I used to gamble on fights. Yeah. Um,
but then I was like,
well maybe I shouldn't be doing this cause I'm doing commentary on these fights,
gambling like of interest. But that was the early days,
like the early two thousands, like 2003 and four and shit like that.
Cause they would have some wacky numbers back then too.
Like guys would come in from other organizations and these oddsmakers didn't
know who they were. And I was a fanatic, so I knew who everybody was.
I knew these guys are fighting in Japan. I was like, well duh, duh,
duh duh duh duh duh, everything got this motherfucker.
Cause there was times where a guy was the favorite and I was like,
that guy has no chance. Like he's going to get your heart right.
And I was right like 80% of the time. Like my friend Aubrey and I, uh,
I've given him tips gotta give him tips now cause I don't care about myself on
it, but we're like at eight 86% winning. Why? Why stop then?
Because of because you're commentating don't, there's no law against it.
I can't affect the outcome,
but I don't want to be sidecar psychologically.
I don't want to be subliminally influenced or subconsciously influenced.
Like wanting someone to win. Yeah. Like if you got $10,000 riding on a fight,
you're going to want that guy. Right. How much of a professional you are. Yeah.
You know, when someone loses, you're going to be like, fuck,
what do you fucking made? The whole thing is like,
you're supposed to be there to do justice to the experience of these two guys
going at it and giving their all right. Supposed to be hoping one guy.
It's true, but it's also really hard for me when a friend's fighting, you know,
like Daniel Cormier, he fights. It's very hard for me to see him very hard.
The last fight with Steve Bay, and I love Steve pay too,
but to watch Steve Bay beat the shit out of Daniel was rough. It was hard. Yeah,
because Daniel is such a good guy. I love that guy.
And to watch him eat those left hooks to the body and then get beaten down,
I was like, Oh that must be hard.
And I'm commentating on it like it's an amazing thing I'm watching. Right.
It is amazing. So it's hard to separate,
you know when Brendan shod was fighting, it was the hardest.
That was the hardest cause I was good friends with him and I knew he really
didn't want to fight anymore and I was God that that's, that's really,
that must be really hard. It was running.
He doesn't want to fight anymore and he just getting beaten.
He was getting beaten and he was getting beaten bad and I didn't,
I didn't see an end to it.
Who is the guy with the nose that went crooked like this recently? Mike Perry,
all that crayon picture's crazy. Crazy.
I can't believe someone can continue fighting when their nose is literally
across their face. That dude's a Savage. I mean, you have to be a Savage.
You go 100% bonafide died in the woods.
Like he literally like imagine what he's fighting through when he has his, his,
his nose over here. It's his face has to be completely numb. Well, well,
no, no, no, no. I mean, I don't know. I don't really know pain. Okay.
Massive pain.
The sinuses are one of the most sensitive areas of your face when you get your
nose shattered. First of all, you can't see,
your eyes are watering and his nose is pouring blood getting choked.
Right. He's in the middle of getting chug on his nose like, Oh,
that is the worst fucking dose I've ever seen in my life of all the years of
calling fights. The only thing that comes close is rich Franklin,
when he fought Anderson Silva pull up a rich Franklin's nose versus Anderson
Silva. And you'll see similar, but not quite as horrific.
But the thing is about rich Franklin was bombed out about his nose, whereas, uh,
you know, Mike Perry was like, fuck yeah, he didn't look at that one.
The far left right there, far left, far left, far left, right there.
Click that one.
That's the one where Anderson Silva sort of reconstructed his nose.
It's hard to see in that picture. Make it larger so that that's as knows after.
Yeah, it's all shifted off to the right. It looks all fucked up,
but that ain't shit.
Compared to Mike Perry's Mike Perry's is the worst knows in the history of the
sport. Did they? F I mean, what does he look like now? What was that guy's nose?
Look, click on that one. In the middle. Above. Above.
It's like Gronk a little bit. Geez. Wow.
Whose fucking noses that she sees us?
It went up into his a forehead look like this.
Worst nose breaks in the UFC. Who is that dude? Yeah.
He looks like it looks like half his nose is, is a up in his eyelids. Oh my God.
That's just swelling. Right? But look how March shift Ryan McGillivray.
Woo. That's rough. Wow. Jesus Christ. Wow.
Yeah. Yeah. No, it's still smiling. Knows he's still smiling there.
Shogun Sjogren's nose got fucked up too. I think that was against Jon Jones.
Yeah. Connely or Connolly's nose got shattered. Yeah, man.
And then you got to get it all reconstructed and they got to sort of stitch the
bones back together again and [inaudible] because if you get this bone shatters,
I'm like, Aw man, there's not much there. You know? It's such a tie.
If you feel that bone, it's like so gentle. So delicate. Yeah.
If you take a knee, they're like, Oh, that's how they're breaking, right? Yeah.
He's all right now. It looks pretty good. Damn.
They did an amazing job. Reconstruct is eating pizza, Aoki pizza,
but it's the crazy thing is his nose was look like the worst situation that you
could possibly get in and his nose now looks pretty normal. Or the other guy's,
his noses are just like that.
One guy with the bowl dropped by his eyebrows like and his nose is still curved
to the right and he's smiling like you'd assume Mike Perry would have that kind
of nose after that. That kind of situation is right after the fight.
You know Mike Perry had to go through extensive surgery overseas.
Where does that, where does that fight take place? Uruguay, South America.
So he had to stay there and get really extensive surgery.
Was there for several days just to try to recover before he could fly home.
The scary thing is his is get back in the ring,
fuck gay is he loves it and then that,
that bone that he's going to have is going to break down again.
Is it going to be weaker or is it going to, I wish I could tell you.
I don't know. You know, it really depends. Imagine if it just shatters again.
He's got to do it again. Yeah man. Wait times got his nose reconstructed.
Who is, what is this? Not a UFC, but it's called
UFC and Africa in Africa kicked in the face. Oh Jane. God,
that's the worst no's ever. [inaudible] Oh my, that's horrible.
Oh my God. Yeah. Oh my God. Oh look at the guy's nose. Oh,
that's the one that Corona said.
Oh the other guy on the bottom is a guy who got his nose damaged somehow or
another and they grew it on his head. Oh yeah. It's a hard businessman.
What kind of exercises do you do? Um, I'm, I like hit training,
high intensity, high intensity, um, and uh, you know,
kind of like blending two worlds. I've, you know, I stopped gambling the casino,
but I love gambling with my friends and I love making prop bets on, you know,
just my recent one was a body fat challenge cause I was at 19.6 April 14th 19%.
Yeah. And then I dropped to, well my,
the bet was if I can drop til 10% in three months,
well that's easy while maybe for someone that really understands how to do that.
But like, you know, I, I wanted to get there and I just like when I work out,
I kind of work out just on the being healthy and cardiovascular and just like,
you know, just staying in shape. But I didn't,
I never thought I'd get below 10%. You must've changed your diet pretty well.
Cut out sugar, cut out bread, cut. Exactly. All that stuff.
Stay below 1800 calories. And you are um, you vegetarian still?
No, I eat chicken and fish, but I stopped eating.
I don't eat any uh, cows or, or uh, you know, uh,
cows, pork pig or um, lamb or anything like that.
But I pretty much stay with the chicken and fish my proteins.
And are you dealing with you that motherfucker walking out looking pretty sure
either way. Below 10% there. What are you there? Um, I think I'm 12.
Really right there. Yeah. Cause like keeping your fat in your brain.
That doesn't make any sense. You know, it's, it's in my eyes. Let me,
I'm probably where I am now because I've, you know,
the bed ended in July 14th, but I did win the bet,
so I made 15 grand from my friends. Ah, that's fine. But I, you know,
that's like how I am motivated to do things.
I like to make bets with people to have these little challenges and then with
that timeline than I, you know, work with my trainer who is, you know,
pull holding the, uh, the towel down and uh,
and he trains me every time I'm home and he gets me on my meal plans.
So I deal with him all the time. Do you do like a meal prep service?
I do it through his company, so I do that company, uh,
diced diced kitchen, I think. Dice kitchen. He's your friend,
huh? I, yeah, but like, you know, he'd like,
it just gets like my assistant puts it in, in the fridge, but you know,
it's all like chicken and vegetables. Pretty much. Turkey, chicken,
fish and then, and then veggies or you drop down to 1800 calories a day,
dropped down to 1800 calories a day.
And this is the hard part is I'm on the road like, you know,
more than 60% of the days when I was not touring across Europe.
And when I'm touring across Europe all summer long, I'm gone.
So how are you getting like really healthy food every meal when you're doing
this? I round ball, uh, you know,
eyeball kind of my calorie count whenever I eat and I have my fitness pal is my,
my judge, you know, is that my fitness pals on an app? It's an app, yeah.
Underarmour app that, that like I just put in all my food,
so I you just use it to just make sure that I am eyeballing this 1800 calorie
deficit kind of diet and then, you know,
just avoid the over starchy over carby foods and focus more on eating the
proteins and the veggies and then that vitamins or supplements. Yeah. Uh,
yeah, like I, I try to, I try to switch it on and off. Like I said, like before,
after, after I met Ray, I was like, okay,
I need to just find out what I'm deficient in.
I'm going to just load up on those. Um,
and then I went to see dr Grossman who kind of gave me my,
like 22 page pack of,
of my telomere links to cancer markers if I have them, you know,
uh, to like what I'm allergic to, to what I'm deficient in. And then,
and then I followed that regimen of what the vitamins I was taking,
some of which was, I still take like, one is called Celergyn.
It's kind of like a, you know, the closest thing to a STEM cell, uh,
like injection if you can, if you swallow it, it's like, you know,
it's got lots and lots of anti aging properties in it.
Celergyn Celergyn what's in it? Uh,
look it up and you could do your Joe Rogan research on that and give me some
more, but I just trusted my doctor on this one, but it's expensive.
It's like $10 a pill. Really pull that up. Seller,
Jen and I take a skeptical hippo face
and I also take a website. Kroger, Kroger.
It's a 1 trillion a probiotics. Oh wow.
It's in a little like I take that every day. Really? Yeah.
For the bio with cell therapies. Celergyn Hmm.
Hello there. Thank you for visiting Selgin's online store pop up window point.
So, um Hm. And this is, what is it?
$2,000 for six months. Damn. It is expensive. It's very expensive.
And what is it backed by a cellular Marine complex. Peptide III.
Collagen bio DNA hydro M N peptide.
Sounds like you're going to piss hot, sir. Other Engli alluded,
teen grape skin extract, set salon selenium, which is important.
Coenzyme Q 10 I take that.
That's one thing that Ray Kurzweil really pushes. Is that that cute 10 yeah.
That's great for cognitive function. Yeah.
You fuck around with mushrooms at all?
I mean like healthy mushrooms like lion's mane or anything like that? No,
really good stuff. That's what I've been drinking.
This is all lion's mane elixir. I'll try that out.
I drink this shit all the time. It supports brain function. Yeah.
That's like anything that's about the brain. I want to know more about. Yeah.
This is one of my sponsors. This is, I'm a four. Sigmatic.
I'll have them send you some of this stuff please. And then we, uh,
we actually have lion's mane that we put in the coffee too. Yeah.
And then layered Hamilton superfood shit.
Have you seen that coffee machine that I have out here? Yeah. Ooh,
I'm going to get you something to drink coffee. Yes. Yes, I do. Okay.
We wrap this up. I'll make you a nice cup of tumeric coffee. Oh,
I love to American. Yeah. Well he's layered.
Hamilton has this amazing machine out there that he gave us.
We got one of the first machines and it's, uh, he mixes, um,
coconut oil, coconut milk, uh, turmeric, organic coffee,
and it's fucking delicious and it's actually very good for you. Wow.
And then he also has like this bag of mushrooms,
cordyceps mushrooms in lion's mane. You can scoop that in there.
But lion's mane in particular is what I'm really interested in because it
supports brain function, you know. And, uh,
have you seen the work of Paul Stamets? Do you know who he is? Yeah.
I'll turn you on to him. Um,
and send you a link to the podcast that I did with him.
He'll blow your fucking mind when he's talking about the power of functional
mushrooms, not just mushrooms, like psychedelic mushrooms,
which he's into that as well.
He thinks it's psychedelic mushrooms in low doses are like one of the most
powerful nootropics that you could have. Like micro dosing. Yeah. Yeah.
But instead of getting blitz out of your mind and going into another dimension,
you're taking just a little bit every day, just a little tiny bit.
And it gives you this like overwhelming, uh, feeling of, uh,
operating at a very high functions, weird feeling.
But it's that micro dosing silicide and thing is swept through the fighter
community has a lot of fighters that are training while they're microdosing
mushrooms. Yeah. It's very interesting. Why are they doing that? Why,
why is it trainers? Why
are, well,
Donald Cerrone's really into it and a few other fighters have followed suit on.
Donald I think started doing it because of Joe Schilling,
who's a world champion kickboxer and he's fighting for Bella tore now and they
just find that there's something about the way it interacts,
the way the psilocybin,
and particularly in low doses interacts with your brain that it just seems to
supercharge your ability to understand what a person's doing.
Like especially specific specifically according to Joe,
when he's sparring with people,
he says he like almost can like read their minds. Wow. Yeah.
That's really interesting. Yeah, very, very interesting. I know a lot of people,
a lot of skiers, skiers like to microdose,
it's becoming this a thing where people try to take like a,
a a functional amount. So like you're not getting blitzed, you're just taking,
it isn't functional now. That's a good question. Good question. Like a, like a,
like a STEM, like a little drop. No, that's even,
I mean the best way to find out what it would be would be to grind it up so you
know the exact ounces and then write it in a capsule and then figure it out.
And I think that's what a lot of these guys are doing.
It's just very unfortunate that that is a schedule one drug. Right.
A natural life form that grows on earth. It's a fungus bounce on a drug.
Yeah. And it's got some pretty potent positive qualities to it.
But outside of, you know, anything that's psychoactive or psychedelic,
that lines main stuff is the shit. Well,
let's put it in this water right now then come on son.
It's going to be a one of these,
it's going to be my Elon Musk smoking weed moment right now.
Nobody gets high off lions, man. Cool. Thank you.
Um, so other than that, other than this, uh, sell stuff, what is it again?
What's it called?
Um, I wish I had like a, my,
someone from my team kinda give me my whole list cause I take something for,
I take a lot of brain cognitive stuff that I know that are, um,
not some might can be considered that way, but it's from my doctor that,
you know, um, you know, from what I,
I do enough research on a doctors and they tell me kind of what I should take
and, and I go, okay, let's try this out and see if, and like, you know, my,
my, uh, performance increases and then I stop.
So I'll do it for like a month and I'll stop and I'll take a different, like,
you know,
I have like two different routes of vitamins and I take a different route and
see if that changes my patterns or how, um, you know,
what my performance is like and that kind of like just experiment over and over.
And again. Have you ever done the isolation tank floating in a, yeah.
Yeah. I love that. Do you do that? I did it twice. It's very new to me,
but it's like, it's incredible. Yeah. You need one of those in your life. Yes.
She can. One of those in your crazy Funhouse I know, I was thinking about that.
There's one place in Henderson where I live that does that.
So I was going to first do that first there. Yeah. Do it man. Um,
we have one here. Yeah. I mean like the, the last two years,
like the ice plunges. Um, I just learned that the Wim Hof method, uh,
love that. Love that. Amazing. I, I've been, I've, I've never met him in person,
but it's great. Yeah. I, you know, I know he's in your, in your lane friends.
He's a character man. Yeah, I've seen the documentary. He's like,
that's what the F like the vice documentary,
that guy just died at all drinks beer and eat spaghetti.
Like he's fucking ridiculous. He doesn't give a shit.
He goes to Everest fucking barefoot clients. Crazy climbs Evers in his shorts.
It's like, it's too easy. Yeah. He's like,
but he gets other people to do with him. Show that like anyone could do that.
Yeah. It's incredible. He is a unique
human being. Like a really true, truly unique human being in,
in the sense that he's just talking about breathing.
He's not talking about doing some sort of incredible athletics that, you know,
a rare few people can achieve.
Now he's talking about concentrating on your breathing and understanding how you
can inhale, like deeper breaths and concentrate on the breath.
And that in doing so you're changing your physiological state and has got a
whole program that shows you how to do it correctly and it enhances your immune
system and enhances your awareness and it's wild shit.
That's incredible. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I tried to do that breath work, uh,
whenever I possibly can. I, there's two people that I've worked with that,
that, uh, trained underneath whim. One of, one of them's in New York as Spain.
So whenever I'm in Majorca, Spain, I meet up with him, we do the breath work,
holding breath exercises, and then we do the ice ice bath.
And then I have one that's based in San Diego, this woman,
and she comes out to Vegas. And then I like to do the group dynamic ice bath.
So I'll have um,
this like pool that's not an ice bath but 50 degrees.
So it's cold enough to like feel it. That's fucking cold. Yeah, exactly. So, uh,
I get like whoever wants to join me, but you like this group kind of, you know,
huddle, we get, get in there, become out, we do the breath work,
hold their breath, you know, and it's,
it's a great way to get people together and experience something like that too.
No, that's awesome man.
The UFC training center, uh, the performance Institute in, uh,
Vegas has this hot bath right next to a cold plunge and they have people going
back and forth between the two. Have you ever been to that place?
Uh,
yeah I shot my music video there cause I had Bruce buffer featuring on a song of
mine called it's time. It's funny,
I didn't bring that up earlier cause you're so tied in with UFC,
but we shot the video there. I was training to fight the other DJ that we,
I made the song with Andy and Bruce. You were trained to fight a DJ? Well,
I mean, the video is like video. You're trained to fight at the UFC,
a facility and a this legendary UFC fighter.
I'm spacing on his name. He was training me,
so it was kind of cool to have him there with me. What'd he look like? Well,
he put up, pick up the,
okay, I'll fine. Can I, can I run to use the bathroom real quick? Sure, sure.
Go ahead. We'll hold this pit. Here we go.
So we're watching it on the video.
A hokey versus Luke is Bruce buffer. So who's training him though? Let's see.
There's all these, uh, people running around Bruce buffer
who is a, who's training him.
I don't see any UFC guy training him,
but you keep jumping ahead. We're not going to see it. Yeah.
Not focusing on there, man. I see it's too quick. Yeah, but who is that? Oh,
it's Ken Shamrock. Oh, eventually here. Oh, there you go.
Ken Shamrock screaming in his face with sunglasses on.
He's a trip, isn't he? Yeah, he's a very interesting guy. Yeah. KC. Me.
Oh my God. That's hilarious. Okay. He's, um, it's,
it's so interesting when you see all these different people have these different
paths in life and you go, Oh, okay, you could go down that path too.
You know, like the Steve Aoki path is so different than most paths.
And I think that one of the cooler things about talking to people is you,
you get this sense that the, the, the way you can live your lives,
not as rigid as people would have you believe. Did,
have you believed that there's only a few different ways to go about this or
this? There's not that much variability. We're saying nice things about you.
He just returned. We watched, it was Ken Shamrock. He was a fighter. Yeah.
He was like, you know, when you do, when you're like,
I was hanging like this and he's just like slept my stomach and stuff. Yeah.
We were watching it. Sunglasses screaming at you. Exactly.
Do you do any martial arts training? Um, you know, strangely enough, like my,
my biggest hero growing up is Bruce Lee. So, you know,
in the beginning I started wanting to learn G kudo and the, you know,
do you see constantly at a time in Hollywood now?
Yet there's a scene in there that's very negative about Bruce Lee.
I loved the movie. I really enjoyed it. I'm a huge Tarantino fan.
I think that's awesome. But this does controversy around that.
But I didn't see that very,
very controversial cause he made Bruce Lee look like a buffoon. Oh, that sucks.
Really arrogant buffoon. Wow.
And I don't think there's any evidence that he was ever really like that. Yeah.
But you know, he Terentino's sorta dug his heels in, sort of defended it.
But I don't think he knows the culture because he's not a martial artist.
I think he looked at,
I think he looked at Bruce Lee as sort of like this historical figure that's,
you know, kicking people's asses and movies.
And I think to understand Bruce Lee the way you do,
or the way I do where he was my childhood hero as well.
So like he's the guy that's really responsible for mixing the martial arts.
When you talk about mixed martial arts, like all credit has to go to the
Gracies because they're the ones who, you know,
Helson Gracie and Horian and hoists and Hixon and that family was responsible
for really showing people jujitsu and also Horian invented the UFC.
So without Horian and his contributions mean we might not have ever known what
we know today. Right.
But Bruce sleep was on that path a long time ago.
He had figured out a long time ago that you got to find what's useful and all
different styles of martial arts. Exactly.
It's also deeply entrenched in philosophy and he was a brilliant guy so they
made him look like this buffoon and then that sucks. I didn't like that.
That's like one of the,
the main things about Bruce Lee that I loved about him was that his,
his philosophy and a lot of things to say about life. Yeah.
Like the martial arts was one thing that's like, well made him cool,
made him such a badass. But his philosophy,
the words behind all that and how it, it,
it can reflect on everyone being like water.
And the best part for me is that he's a,
he's an Asian face because I mean at the end of the day,
you think about what's out there in the media and popular culture.
You don't see an Asian face that's loved by all different ethnicities.
Yeah. He's the number one. He's the, the, uh, like every,
does it matter if you're black, white, Brown, purple, yellow, whatever you are,
you're like, yeah, you have to honor, like one of the greats,
everybody likes Bruce Lee and he's Asian.
So he represents something very powerful for Asian people.
How many Chinese dudes got laid because of Bruce Lee? Exactly. Fuck man.
The numbers probably if you take the main how many Chinese people that got laid
with non-Chinese women. Oh yeah. That's like, cause at the end of the day,
the women loved Bruce Lee. Everybody loved, yeah. Everyone. Everybody. Yeah.
And there hasn't been someone like that, you know, uh,
that has that striking feeling. That's Asian in popular culture like that,
you know? So also like the first guy that was really shredded in movies. Yeah.
We'd take his shirt off. No,
you definitely got that stance that she was just like, yeah,
he was fucking shredded and you would look at him and you go, God,
that guy's body's ridiculous. Like everybody wanted that body.
Everybody wanted to be lean and muscular.
And that's where I got my room from at my house. That Bruce Lee, game of death,
right? Yeah. That's the dragon. That's end of the dragons.
At least for me. I got the mirror from enter the dragon,
but that the mirror room scene is way more mirrors like kind of in different
degrees and yeah, it was, it was entered the dragon, right? Yeah. Yeah.
It was hundred a dragon. Fuck. That was a good movie.
And for the time those movies, you know, people don't like them or do like them.
What's interesting about Bruce is the style of fighting and those movies like
jumping, flying kicks and all that stuff, that's not what he advocated at all.
He did that purely the cinematic value.
Right. He wanted to make it exciting and flashy. Yeah.
Like he was all about kicking people in the knees, punch of people throat,
you know,
like he was about like really effective techniques that you could use to end a
fight in seconds. You know, that was what he was all about. Yeah.
But what he did do was there was like two big bursts in martial arts and Bruce
Lee was responsible in my opinion, for the first,
he was responsible for getting people excited about training martial arts and
seeing this guy that could kick everybody's ass. And like this guy was like,
he was quiet and humble, but you know,
when it came time to throw down and take his shirt off and fuck everybody up.
And then the next stage was the UFC. Those are like in my lifetime,
this to two big really culturally,
the two big leaps in martial arts was people getting into Bruce Lee because of
getting into martial arts because of Bruce Lee movies. Of course chocolate bars,
movies. Yeah.
And then the next one was getting into martial arts because of the UFC. Right?
So it was bomber. It was a bomber that they made them look like a dope.
That sucks.
I'm as excited to watch that movie because I thought that Bresee was gonna look
like about us. Cause in the, in the, in the trailer. Yeah. You're like, Oh no.
Bruce Lee's in there. Like it's going to be cool with, yeah. With Brad Pitt.
Leonardo DiCaprio. Quinn Terentino's is going to be Epic.
It's a fucking great movie. Know, don't let it hold you back because the movies,
fun shit. I really enjoyed it. It's a fun look. I like all those movies I loved,
hateful, ate a lot of people don't like hatefully it. Oh, I loved it.
I think his movies are, if you're into like a Tarantino movie,
like I like his style of making fiction. Yeah, the Django. Yeah.
They're wild. They're great films. Absolutely great films. Such a fan.
I'm just glad he's out there because it's like, there's mu,
there's moments in that movie where I don't wanna S I'm not gonna give anything
away, but there's moments in, in Hollywood, where are you going?
I can't believe you could still do this in a movie, like on this day and age,
like you're allowed to do that in a movie. He goes hard while in the paint.
Yeah. But the Bruce Lee things, you know, whatever you gotta do,
it wasn't real. The real Bruce Lee is what's interesting and exciting to me.
Right. You know, I mean, that's where like my,
my record label democ it's, you know, you know a democracy. Yeah.
I mean it's not necessarily tied to Bruce Lee, but it's my way of,
of like, you know,
instead of calling it Bruce Lee records or I love Bruce Lee records. Right.
I was like, well, this is this mysterious death touch. And you know,
there's, like I said,
that this mystery around that that's connected sort of to Bruce Lee. There's,
yeah. It would be really interesting if there really was a demonic,
like a mysterious death touch if it was, it was real.
But a lot of fucking people believe in it. If you ever see those videos on,
on when they to fall down. Yeah.
That does make dojo life on Instagram was kind of a shit load of,
and this guy just collects them all.
And there's so many of them that are so ridiculous.
I posted one a couple of days ago of this, uh,
it looks like an Aikido guy and he's just like doing this like watch,
watch this video kinda comes out and he's like, pushes him away. Oh,
I makes you fall down.
So you stand there like a tall one. Oh,
you fall down. Look at him. You wow Brown.
No power here. It's so ridiculous. It is. It's
playing. He believes it. Yeah. It's so,
so fucking evangelical preachers that like they touched in someone's head and
the guys like falling over. Yeah. And they're all practicing it.
Look like they're all practicing.
All this nonsense will get you killed in a real fight and these guys are leaving
their house. They're putting on their fucking outfit. Right.
It really think that this is real. This is actually happening. Yeah.
It's so corny. It really is what you're going do.
Well listen man, I really enjoyed talking to you. I appreciate it.
Thanks for having me. Your book blue. The color of noise is available right now,
right it everywhere. It's out everywhere. Did you do the audio book?
Did you read it? I read the, there's drops in there.
It's called what I call drops. You're like the, the,
these small little chapters between the chapters. So I read those. Um,
I try to read the whole book,
but I was touring all summer so I could only read the drops. That's too bad.
But yeah, I'd like to hear you read it. Especially since it's your life. Yeah,
there, there is like 10 drops,
so you can hear me talk about it in my tone and my voice.
And if people want to catch your live show,
where can they get information on where to go? Uh, Steve, aoki.com everything.
Stevie Oakey online. It's pretty simple. All right, well thank you brother.
Appreciate it, man. Thank you for having me. Bye everybody.